le podcast de cette semaine et présenté
par un vive encore une fois vous les
connaissiez pour l'heure smoothie
maintenant ils ont sorti des lunch et
ont sorti 3 1 et qui se trouvent être
des repas complets et le tome taille il
ya le banc le chili et y est le max
couach la semaine prochaine de ce fait
le max quoique le chili jal et en chili
ce méfait chili tchéquie sa langue vive
comme ça c'est que si vous n'avez pas le
temps de faire un à côté c'est à dire du
riz des nouilles ou élevé peut juste les
manger en soupe
c'est clair je vais me faire le bal
chili version sûr je veux juste prendre
ce ici je le pape dans le vol comme
celui là je fais juste mettre un petit
peu d'eau mais cela micron 3 me fait
quand il ya des haricots maïs lalime du
support clé c'est de tester
[Musique]
ok ça a l'air bon sèche il alors les
repos vif des repas complets 100%
naturel vegan et au visage un code promo
avec le code promo s'infiltre podcast 10
pour 10 % de rabais sur votre 1ere
commande alors bon appétit
le podcast est également présentée par
même skype
vous connaissez même script mais on va
en parler encore parce que je vais
parler pour moi je vais pas parler pour
doigt mais moi c'est un de mes coups de
coeur de l'année 2020 cette découverte
lorsque la ligne benoît et ehrhoff quand
même on se cache poste mais en
découvrant mainstage et couvrez j'ai
découvert pardon un monde de possibles
une petite lueur d'espoir dans une marée
noire vous a déjà parlé du perfect
package 3.0 avec le tri mort la mort 3.0
avec sa technologie qui empêche de
nickel et bal avec le fait que
waterproof donc dans l'espace en laisse
pas partout en fait j'adore thales
partout tu pars essaient par tous ces
grands les bras tendus si ce n'est toi
c'est parfait
on a parlé du bateau ne l'est
aujourd'hui on vous parle de quelque
chose d'autre d'homme c'est quoi on a
ici le parfum le parfum manuscrits find
pauvres et sans vraiment vraiment bon
c'est vraiment quelque chose que fait
sentir à la gente féminine c'est qui qui
trouva n'était pas juste de gars qui se
sentaient on the event chambon big on
s'est fait dire que ça sentait bon
effectivement m a bola ça sent bon
c'est vraiment quelque chose que je
porterai le pauvre et c'est vraiment un
super bon parfois attaquer le terminer
l'angoissent ds que ce que je sent
mauvais ce qui ma partenaire mon
partenaire vous trouvez que j'ai pas une
odeur incroyablement sexy avec ce le
vous allez être incroyablement sexy
il y en eut aucun doute puis on nous
c'est notre produit mes scripts qui le
croque mort c'est ce moment les gars là
où est ce que tu es prends ma poche et
vous tu es chez quelqu'un de cinq
périodes qui voit quelque chose qui va
se passer
pif ou ta femme tu as salle de bain de
passer le l'entrejambe lens ou de lévis
est ce que vous y en a quatre si vous
voulez et à cette histoire dit vous qui
êtes drôlement besoin de croque-mort
chrome os est humide sans bon fait
qu'ils sentent la même odeur que que ce
parfum le c'est l'odeur minsk est en
fait même le bal tourneur le dr
d'horizon pour bâle c'est le même genre
dodo mois pis le nettoyer avec ce cas
vous allez sans ces fraises comme si
vous sorti de la douche dans cette
région le sens parfait plus d'inquiétude
est-ce que chipeau parfaitement propre
vous savez que vous êtes parfaitement
propre et qui vous sentez très bon y est
on a un code promo évidemment pour vous
c'est sans fil dans un mauvais pour cent
de rabais plus le shipping gratuit next
level pour le
pour tous en fer chez mindscape donc le
perfect paquet 3.0 plus le parfum le
crop up et tous leurs autres produits
donc allé voir ce petit merci la chine
skate pour retrouver un petite parcelle
de bonheur dans cette année même script
mêmeté le pro des tags faudrait pas
gâcher quelques concept arts marketing
piercing une production du studio sfr
nous sans filtre le podcast on parle de
ce qu'ont vécu nos invités dati site
juppé h 30 avec moi dôme plantes
si vous voulez nous encourager au sans
fil podcast si vous pouvez vous abonner
à notre page piquionne ça coûte trois
pièces par mois vous avez accès à tous
les podcasts en avance et vous avez
aussi accès aux encore moins de filtres
ou est ce qu'on dit à montlouis fonds
goût à propos du la compensation
convient d'avoir fait qualité que seul
le nombre est dans la déception du pakao
hier cette semaine
andréanne marquis c'est vraiment le fun
on a parlé de ses humbles commencement
dans l'univers la politique son passage
occupation double qu'elle gagne et
maintenant son sa vie en tant
qu'entrepreneur sa business les
dernières années jusqu'aujourd'hui il
raconte comment que ça a été assez
difficile au début
le sac comment ça banalise à faire donc
on est bien content pour elle puis
c'était vraiment un super drôle espère
finesse par le funk qui est vraiment un
beau podcast brian rahill tous une
philanthrope dans l'angle qui redonne au
suivant donc
1 grâce à son super intéressante les cd
ripping des commentaires comme job des
étoiles des vous savez ce coiffeur
abonnés wang chen et me wade bon podcast
hu
[Musique]
je t'avais écrit black tellement
longtemps
baptiste rapide avec rib l'a tellement
honte en place avait pas donné que tu
viennes sur le podcast puis on s'est
croisé l'autre fois pu me suis dit je
suis revenu j'ai déjà on va juste et ça
va vraiment votre [ __ ] je sais pas ça
marche mais en fait jeudi soir les
africains n'ont pas de bon sens pis même
état athlètes du juste comme dans ton
entourage
on sait maintenant sur le sujet
médiastore tu peux tellement dur en
affaire qui peut mal finir que moi ça
m'a angoissé ce pauvre et le mon
entourage laisser effet que des fois c
est dominant dit et de sortu est allé
leur genre à bord physique des corps
d'un homme à monter bob abbey n'allait
comme un gourou spirituel ajouté tout
petit chantilly après une enquête mobile
et cameron trois autres des attentes
mais en fait des folies pas beaucoup de
films
pis ça votre proche métis pas si pire
que ça c'est juste que on a tous dans
les derniers temps j'ai tellement vu de
gens qui se sont mis dans les situations
épouvantables je me dis qu'ils fine scan
sa pote bon ça mais je sais pas on dit
tout des africains feux de brousse un
pilote et moi je veux je suis moi mais
tu sais où mais qui est tellement tâche
à moi j'en ai tellement poker en école
de mini sens tu te sens tu qu'avec
d'une large présence sur instagram qui
es qui toi en fait le tout sans sucre
comme ça tu crées dessus de la l'anxiété
km 11 je prends ton c'est l'habitude dit
quelque chose de sacré pas de l'anxiété
mais je suis éperdument que je ne dis
pas tout ce que je voudrais bon sens
pour sans toi non non non victimes mais
dans le fond dedans vise en général je
sais pas là on veut je vois plus mes
amis mais ça chaque fois qu'on se voie
entre amis y ait toute intrusion dans
gagnacais suspense de tous - c'est sur
un sujet qui plus est chez moi j'ai
séchage est en amour avec la politique
les gens j'en manque c'est ma deuxième
carrière et écoute pour l'arc
j'écoutais mon polar matin qu'elle
écoute sur mon celle de de chez nous à
au bureau qui genre 12 minutes et la pop
et ses maquettes a gagné jalouse de
polars canal c'est seulement maintenant
mais le week end où les vendredis st
martin france martin n'a remarqué qu'il
faut faire quand on a passé vendredi
puis l'un des gros hits la patate c'est
toi c'est son bébé le juge magi moi
c'est ok mais là aucun sens le match que
tu ta bref pas des paroles de paul un
matin pour moi c'est comme à qui tu es
bon en avant la musique je te lis
souvent son show et pas du tout je
comprenait vraiment ce qu'on peut sinon
c'était c'était bon c'était drôle parce
que ces deux civils des femmes à des
questions qui sait il faut quelqu'un tv
comme c'est qui lui
l'économie d'un chai pauvres mais t4
site intéresse pop si ce débris d'un
mannequin
non mais c'est parce que c'est la
politique qui tous les champs connexes
de la société c'est tellement l'arc de
commenter tout ce qu'est ce que les vox
pop serov un petit aigle
l'immortel qui fait des vagues c'est
comme moi je me considère comme
quelqu'un qui suis quand même dit le
paysage socioculturel du québec puis je
qu'approche le norfolk kasiki ce qui est
en question de commande maintenant il y
avait plein d'autres je dis pas parce
que je pense que je connais quelque
chose mais je connais pas tout s'est tu
m'as soit puis tu me demandes de nommer
télé dernier premier ministre dans les
années 90 je pourrais pas te le dire
mais je te connais pas ça dans le fond
je tendance troupes et non un livre
d'histoire
mais ce n'est pas tout c'est juste il
est quand même pendant cinq ans et aux
gens que tu t'intéresses à quelque chose
est certaine à ce que tu maîtrises de
sujets comme si jean soulard enseignant
à l'école
ouais c'est clair c'est claire o'petit
c'est tellement et c'est tellement
points au dessus de ces justes et
mettons enseigner un sujet à l'école le
crime comme tu mentionnes laitiers en
cours de trois heures qui ça va tourner
autour d'un seul sujet c'est des prépas
soral enseigne à l'université en ce
moment puis c'est monter un court le lci
prend 40
ces genres un cours complet pour monter
un petit cool trop précis puis affecté
mais dans tous les cas l'intérêt que tu
portes à la politique ça fait longtemps
que tu as tu toujours dessus et en fait
ça fait parti de nulle part je mange
avec comme ça va avoir 18 ans 18 environ
c'est dans un super soir à
rivière-du-loup - julien de l'hiver
là-bas pied marmara une entreprise de
plantes une dernière de botanique skins
bannière de rona puis il y avait comme
un galet d'entreprise chez pas trop le
cheval est là avec elle et l'auto
d'osséja
j'étais aussi j'ai mes mots le cégep
[Rires]
tout à fait quoi et 6e
mais bon c'est directement en même temps
que prenne quelques sorties c'est tout
ce que je me rappelle du poivre et j'ai
étudié en comptabilité gestion a
expliqué noah québec nous parce que mes
deux meilleures amies maria riesch
allant du secondaire c'est des jumelles
raisons de son geste comme hergé comme
un juste partage enfin gestion et
comptabilité
j'ai fait trois ans et une technique de
trois ans j'ai fait comme deux ans deux
ans et demi mais à chaque session en
matant condamine qui comprenait un rien
du tout bien mes proches mes profs
menacé toute passivité comme on va
t'aider la saison prochaine et jean
charles v comme en fiscalité
j'ai bien vu la différence entre une
colonne débit crédit jeux des casinos
pour moi j'allais voir un oriental j'ai
fait il faut que vous fabriquez toursime
je comprends rien je comprenais rien
puis maso tu penses tu as aux besoins de
toute la comptabilité d'environ 0 que
c'est quand je vois jamais
d'entrepreneurs de toute ma vie si
j'aime les chiens entrepreneurs un jour
appelez moi en faire plaisir cette
immensité son temps n'a pas de besoins
métiers qui sont tassés de crédit
pendant index formation puis selligent
que ça faisait quoi indexant mention ce
contrôle médical et aux grands pitié des
gants on va leur donner les dates qui
fait j'ai dit ah c'est sûr se faire du
pognon d'études collégiales sans mention
tout si ces vagues mais j'ai fait en
tout cas c'était à ce moment le peuple
atchan
c'est vraiment moche d'aller dans l'île
d'or du mot quand je te ranger et izon
comptabilité-gestion chacun d'entre eux
peut être juste pas je pensais que je
voulais tu avocate retail faut que je
veux être traité des disques et non je
suis pas vo avant après ou encore dalida
est reçu premier tech a review son
entrée des factures en longueur de
journée moi je comme comptabilité c'est
ce qu'il poursuive sa fait 2 chez dance
flick membres appuient le député de la
gironde a reverdi dans ce temps les
gendarmes ont interpellé idée qu est ce
que tu t'intéresses à la politique
chacun ouais moi
mes jambes on engage des étudiants dans
les cabinets politiques tottenham a
manqué peut-être une passe à québec je
prends maintenant c'est oui oui
j'attends petite gêne c'est une passion
pour moi le premier politicien et que je
raconte officiellement mais je non mais
parce qu'ils débarquent et nabeul
jaillit un autre view mabrouk el hammam
row dont l'ipod steak moi je suis du
coup insisté la ministre
sina ministère des affaires municipales
occupation territoire québécois qui se
veut témoin quant à kleinmond à prix
mondiaux entre les membres ou méjean les
autres parlent comme le pardon de
débarquer là bas je savais pas du tout
où j'étais je savais pas du tout qu'est
ce que je faisais déjà des correctifs de
france est en tout cas final j'ai eu le
job vraiment rapide toute ma vie
maintenant le cabinet de la triperie
cabinet qui en parle de ces échanges à
12 heures exquises les principaux enjeux
mais georges comme un enjeu qu'est ce
que c'est j'aime penser qu'un cabinet
politique jusqu'à jeudi assis dedans
bien avec sursis enjamba du bixi et qui
est comme moi je parlais derrière de
l'île verte
j'ai même pensé comme un bixi j'ai même
pensé quoi et bixi c'est un gros enjeu
parce qu'à montréal un ample cape de ces
gens ne me cache pas arriver le système
le gros des bonnes after de québec est
ce qu'ils venaient en europe
gloss tester cabinet lui qui allait
comme un peu parce qu'il était une
enfant municipal qu'elle est un peu cher
et ce avec moi j'ai quand même rentrer
là-dedans pilote est de ne pas prendre
tout est connue qui prend toutes les
informations qui comme rapatrie sur tout
un peu et finalement ça steve c'était
vraiment intéressant penchard va ce
moment les plus gros enjeux municipaux
et plus design mais j'étais du genre est
trop mois puis chargé fait déchiquetage
point de vue c'est dur ici c'est la
seule à savoir qu'au gouvernement iyad
montre aucune dit qu'est ce que j'en dis
c'est 50 dollars mais j'ai fait des
sketches à traiter en fait c'est juste
quantité de filetage et tue
littéralement du déchiquetage de parler
de bixi qui avait vu tes yeux
dit ok on va mettre le déchiquetage ne
regardais même cause mais finalement ça
vraiment c'est une façon de dire j'ai
fait acquis gens j'aime vraiment
apprécié le talent étudia à towers en
plein casting politique parce que
d'abord en ontario ont pas de ses jets
moment avec mon ex en mensonge comme tu
te fais passer quand même
ôta s'était surtout m'appelait génie va
très bien disait oui ce que l'ontario
jarry fayçal était d'abord un thème 4 et
politique qui sait après mais j'ai pas
j'ai fait une entorse et est revenu à
rodez ok c'est dans ta vie j'avais un
après midi d'été justement comment sait
comment ça arrive ce que matheuse
commenté décidé de faire mais en fait
moi je n'ai jamais pris l'avion de ma
vie et qui me vient d'une famille est
plus que normal les gens n'étaient pas
pauvre mais on allait manger de stars
une fois par année au st-hubert python
est en voyage et peut si on met deux
parents sont entrepreneurs existait
beaucoup dans un peu dans business news
j'ai vraiment du monde de d'études et si
on n'a pas de ces possibles mon époux
jean une gamine de comme on va faire ce
pire en double ça va être ce tempérament
des gens de tout dépendant on est bien
dans la vie de tous les jours à tous les
jours puisque comme ceux dont la vie
soit légende région c'est plus comme
ceux ci pas dans le même genre je pars
en voyage en cinq mois non c'est comme
aujourd'hui sur le dos mais s'arrête à
la fois rapide et ne fait que ça faisait
pas partie de nous tous de voyage et
tant que ce pays très pauvre et le plus
loin que je t'en aller le d'est en ouest
et nord sur le steak omet gaspésie puîné
gamiq signed by à ottawa
certains rayons finalement je suis pas
un après midi l'une des mes amis étaient
comment vous enfin les outils dont 10
sur la coque puissamment j'ai été pris
de grands ensembles
j'avais 20 22 cela en veine de la marque
terme le 31 juillet j'étais parti le 22
ou le toqué rage le 30 35 ans elle même
âge c'est drôle parce que moi moi
mettons là
souvenirs de de te regarder à od parce
que tu es la seule saison la première en
tout cas j'ai regardé c'est que vous
étiez tous vraiment plus vieux que moi
puis j'ai comme pagny 1,2 me tiens je
suis cuit le riquet tête on en rit puis
à comme dirait ma femme dans deux
semaines lemagit n'est d'avoir ma faute
je vais avoir 30 indiqué les avoir 31
ans dans deux semaines je te camardes
marc michel taride je sais pas les
écoutes moi des fois j'ai connu des
brides mais nous ne t'a mis tout un tas
de cod t'avais ce soit ce c'est super le
témoin de ma vie c'est comme si je pris
soin en californie c'est juste que j'ai
fait mes valises pour bus mais moi je
suis comme ça je vois pas le nom jamais
lu d'allemagne
je m'envoie en californie la probité
comme m
non mes machines bac une fois moi je
suis moi-même d'abord je me suis dit
[ __ ] défaut j'avais déjà j'ai fait
comme peut-être de leur ennemi ok je
t'ai déjà c'est sûr que je resterai pas
longtemps finalement le film après les
récents ça fait tellement longtemps
s'est dit lui même un croyant même un
tapis faute à l'impression c'était il ya
six mois je pense tous à tressauter des
fois je vois des brides des missions
puisque la réponse que l'on tente et je
me rappelle de di des émotions vécues
quand tu regarde l'émission est ce que
tu te vois toi et moi j'ai fait
l'expérience dernièrement le regard des
missions puis je vois pas la même
personne que je suis maintenant le ton
ben non oui parce que moi je suis
vraiment naïdji d'une grande naïveté
si je trouve que shy'm a fait la clameur
gens sont vraiment charmant même affaire
puis je suis content de l'avoir fait un
stage elle est aujourd'hui tous les
jeunes danseurs leurs frais tu surpris
mais pas à 30
je condamne cet acte bagages que j'avais
qui étaient minimes qui peut-être une
14e ou des on se souciait pas de renard
avant oui oui on sait on à ravoir de
convenance et surtout nous rivière du
loup la vie claire fait avant nous
c'était marc pierre maurice allais
vraiment mal et est il avait fait
éclater comme mon dieu si je veux donc
monter quand j'ai fait un don sans mes
parents devant et par extension double c
mais on dit rires
elle me ment pas j'ai annoncé à mon père
pour avoir soixante dix ans dans deux
semaines selon baseball quand je rentre
vraiment dans cette partie à taoussa
pensais pas que ce fait c'est quand j'ai
décidé jalel dizaines vers ottawa
j'avais tout contracter mais prêts
auprès des banques avant d'être à mes
parents j'ai comme ils vont capote et
puis quand j'ai dit alpha blondy en
dépenses l'explicatif les pamphlets
bercy non mais dans ce temps le séjour
travaux qui à défaut non mais toi
c'était quoi les gens que tu as toi mais
tu sais ça ce que tes parents ça c'est
toi mais pas tant la jetée comme moi
étaient 6 e par équipe et je n'ai pas de
télé bonne chère et qui s était pas la
même
vraiment pas la même game fair maintien
puisque l'athlète du gang des puits tu
reviens ici le même temps qu'on veut
continuer la chrono mais j'y vais pour
voir qu'est ce qui t'a mine jusqu'à
maintenant tu reviens ici avec un condo
ouais ce qui quand même considérable
oui le condo dans ce temps là qu'arrive
mois sur métro mais il fallait vous
n'habitiez non non non il fallait pas on
habite en 8 à montréal dans le
feuilleton ici puis fallait pas qu'on la
billette on le louis et apprécions le
moi j'allais habité quand j'ai commencé
ou même devant le fond meetic au stop de
beloeil est commis en réunion deux clubs
phares d'apple il fait comme jean le
monde devant la télé ce fatras doute se
faire coiffer chat et hoëdic en
radiotéléphonie fête arc
j'ai vraiment peur c'est un work à
chaque matin je me lève en disant ça se
peut que j'avais pu job parce que
personne pas pelt a pas de job comme à
la merci du monde j'ai comme mais quel
milieu un certain que je prenne comme
les afghans dessus bénéficie d'une
tribune instantané ouais c'est dans le
sens où tu es toujours à merci de pas de
faire renouveler parce que le thé
populaire des peuples up
tepa block pas qu'il soit plus donc
c'est ce petit quand tu fais ou des
tulles c'est sûr que tu l'as vécu quand
tu sors donné l'intelligence c'est pas
quelque chose qui peut ta partenaire
auprès de la société des gens et
présentant les débits gens c'est prohibé
l'indigence n'appartiendra jamais celui
des caniches se fait avant mais après
dix mois
rien à perdre et je m'en fous nous
t'aimons faire associés au dispositif
qui me dérange sauf qu'à jeter des
papiers par quelques a montré que les
gens d'occupation double ce sont des
humains à part entière qui sont toutes
différentes
non non c'est vrai qu'à pratiquer en
quête d'une vie montagne par des
grillades au bilan mieux rien fait après
il vit ça lui fait ce qu'il doit faire
quelque chose doit évidemment affectée
c'est un peu déplacé se jeter comme
tomber là-dedans fait pendant que cacher
entre eux un milieu je me dis non c'est
un temps de pause et un milieu qui est
écrit me tentait pas toute ma tante est
peu fofolle une fille non plus de gosses
et j'aime pas les gens de soieries
trinque à ces demandes et que j'ai fait
c'est beaucoup d'affectif finalement
s'il fait beau je serai pas là dedans
bien tout genre excuse mais je crois
qu'au ps que jean marc pères maristes et
des jeux connus popularité déjà un
modèle du genre m
justement c'est comme tu dis j'ai
l'impression que dans la tête du monde
c'est comme tout le monde doit être une
personne du public
watson au dip c'est ce que tu veux pas
rater c'est à la roue des parce que
c'est suffisait pas et n'en étaient pas
ce qu'elle gère
je dirais j'attende que je vis le moment
présent parce que j'ai pas vraiment pas
ce que je voulais c'est nécessairement
pis plus que ça va avancer plus que je
me rende compte que c'est parce que je
viens non plus jean vraiment pas fait
qu'après sage et j'y retourne et trompe
et c'est un fondement prix hormis ce
genre mais tenez temple non mais le job
stand red jean-pierre jeunesse mois
jusqu'à ce que j'ai appris c'est la
mêlée
[Rires]
depuis le quand j'avais très envie la
première fois que ma malgré une
politique avait germé en moi je devrais
en charge et je pense j'avais 24 ans
quand j'ai voulu rentrer ailleurs
cabinets politiques ont été solides eux
j'étais prête
puis si j'allais un peu si j'avais comme
compris t on les gens parlent dit qu'on
y met jamais de l'avant gens voient
jamais si on voit toujours le ou la
ministre qui dit quelque chose qui a pas
de bon sens et tout ce qui intéresse les
médias mais se montre le cddb le mental
notamment j'arrivais au cabinet plus je
dis jamais c'est on va affronter rêve au
cabinet et 5 heures réveil matin ton
mini ce qui est déjà arrivé et a dit sa
revue de presse au complet il maîtrise
ses dossiers tels enjeux tels enjeux tal
afar
ces gens s'en servent pis c'est un
montant qui a mené politiques ont pas de
contrat de travail
ces foules sont attachés à leurs
ministres mais cela ministre entre
nantes et vidic toi c'est terminé c'est
terminé ou si l'armée ne se fait pas ils
essaient sans ministre par sa job ils
perdent tout leur job parce qu'ils
savent que qu'elle est menée ce qui
arrive après désormais tout doute
c'est quand même sait déjà qui donne
puis moi c'est le piège quand j'ai
travaillé en politique car j'y
retournais en politique chère au coeur
des débats dû quitter l'éducation
instant que j'y fais pipi même si je
mets autant d'un manque de passion pour
un projet quitte à moi ce que j'en dis
leur que j'aime et se rendre compte que
je pouvais peut-être ma partir en avant
en quémener politique ce que tu penses
pas une tout ces gens là qui sont calmes
népotique c'est débile
parce que tu dis tu jouais du monde
travailler de façon acharnée toi même tu
mens tu énergie la pts 10 je me serais
mère juliette dans un projet qui
pourrait miner maintenant whaychi
réflexion qui s'incruste un peu la
réflexion reste et pesant au sud termine
m l'énergie pour quelqu'un d'autre c'est
plus ses pigistes
ces gens là ils changé cave n'est pas
utile il faut pas juste comme de
l'éducation il s'adapte à toutes des
vrais caméléons ils réapprennent les
dossiers pour ils mettent en action puis
ça sert à une école de haut qui dans le
fond tu peux tu adaptes à n'importe quel
sort va situation plus tu le payes
petits votes s'il fait c'est juste comme
fou tu le fasses tes à d'autres sont en
hausse ont sont au bas
le typhon qui ça m'a comme c'est sa main
peut germer l'anarchie mastic m il y
aurait quelque chose qui me tenterait
parce que tu es je pense pas que j'aime
et paule ka venait pas
sic mais c'était comme un genre de tichy
page afm qui a tranché si j'essaye
baptiste était pas tout son argent
puis tout avait des parts entreprenons
infecte avait au moins ceux des jeux de
suite avec l'espèce de huntington
possibilité d'un new nommé jean mais moi
mes parents mes parents sont séparés
depuis comme chez paul 12 13 ans puis
ils ont fait leur business enfants et
qui s'appelait je pense dans le temps de
rêve d'entente et jardins de reims et
2000 l'union des jardineries botanic spi
et france et deux horticulteurs des
métiers ma mère est fleuriste aussi
qu'ici c'est un gros centre jardin puis
bon on me met pas s'en séparer n'est pas
en fait faillite dans le fond qui m'en
racheter la business avec sa famille
allaient me dérobe à ses parieurs ce
moment là je fais tout ce que je
continue ou je t'attends ok parfait
pis si ça fait qu'ils ont toujours eu
cette décence en jetant j'avais genre 7
18 ans puis j'ai quatre chez qui est ami
par mes jambes je n'avais jamais catch
avec ce temps mais je n'ai jamais caché
que ont fait faillite comme 4 juin qui
dans le fond reste était élevé parce que
t'es pas failli depuis je me rappelle on
ramasse un truc dans le magasin qui ont
été jeunes qui change avec un 17 18 19
20 ans le g4 et à kista aux enfants à au
point que c'est eux qui payent leur art
du monde sait où qui engage le monde
ceux qui font des artisans j'avais
jamais 400 ont dû penser qu'ils
travaillaient comme un employé mais
j'avais peur 4 celle importante d'abord
ça désigne été le poc de ses épaules
nous ont jamais fait mentir ça jamais
jamais jamais non à la seule affaire qui
m'ont dit si tu vas passer deux tiers de
taille a travaillé ensuite faire quelque
chose qui est m six ans après sept jours
sur sept on n'a jamais senti
jamais jamais sentie très c'est de la
responsabilité petits pots d'avoir une
belle
mais dans les a jamais senti telle image
d'un entrepreneur ou un collègue m'a
baptisé enfants n'ont jamais feinte des
gens sages à mes côtés c'est comme à mon
activité je me dis specht et jetaient
généalogique chez sa tante
18 ans c'est quand même assez fort mais
l'entrepreneuriat et était peu à mon âge
quand j'avais 18 ans tuée de douze
quinze ans c'était pâques et de citer
aussi mis de l'avant aujourd'hui
vraiment qu'ils en oublient qu'ils en
entrepreneuriat là bas c'est pas une
question de profitabilité puis de grosse
business de grosses pancartes sont un
enfer de thé krays ta propre job les
autres c'est ce qu'ils ont fait ils se
paient leur propre et sans la maison
mais on met son mais possède l'avant on
avait 12 ans et de décider quel genre de
vie tu fumes veut mener parce que si tu
veux que travailler 80 heures semaine du
peu mais si tu travailles et 30 en
semaine
tu peux aussi tout c'est eux qui
décident quels genres de genre de train
de vie quel genre de petit ou jusqu'où
tu poursuis le lait de la crosada bernès
est pas tout le monde qui est quelqu'un
qui est à peine yang jiechi gros plus
gros plus gros de nantes
c'est clair c'est clair puis fait clair
toi tu te dis je veux me partir moi mais
est-ce que met-on est ce que le projet
romaine c'est à regret maintenant la
question lequel qui en fait la question
que je me pose c'est ce qu'incarne 80,15
mettons moi je me vois l'entrée par
l'entrepreneuriat puis je l'imaginé
comme andrée 2 il ya deux options il ya
la première qui est de deux options pour
entrer dans la pompe les mariés en fait
ça fait sens il ya la première qui j'ai
un projet que je menais à terme puis par
ricochet jeu devient entrepreneur parce
que ce projet est un projet mettant
comme le studio un peu ici le trio est
ce que nous on a fait enfin studio fait
qu'on on devient entrepreneur parce que
c'est le projet qu'on veut foretz et
puis de l'autre aspect qui est au ski
qui tu veux at entrepreneurs paix tu
cherches un projet le tc de le trouver
ma tendance est un peu pas de quel côté
tu entrer là dedans
le départ de tout ce qui peut compter
c'est souvent moi j'avais jargon kim
avait rejoint puis m'avait dit vous
laisse partir une genre de boutique en
ligne mais de cosmétiques mais qui était
pas vraiment vente au canada avec jantes
et des fois tu vends voyage pictural
j'entends nuit le bronze en khl de
schiphol et comme on dit jamais vraiment
vu qu'à ce moment aucun adolescent
français mais moi je t'ai comme vraiment
en bonne fille de créer le genre
vraiment pop moelleux la peau sèche
spécialité mais mardi matin je partage
[Musique]
[Rires]
mes culottes et comme a sorti dé 6,4 en
2011 2012 on va donner d'autres puits
dans cinq centres existent et paul jean
véronis pas g début c'était pour y est
dit
les entreprises paient pas pour t0t dans
les accessoires
dès demain je puisse vraiment le type
qui me dernier en 200 pièces moi quand
je passe un coup de com' 0,1 en rythme
été jetés à mathon sait pas c'est que
tel coton c'est possible nuri sahin
comme année j'ai pas son argent
évidemment j'ai d'autres choses que des
déchets
[Rires]
finalement quand lui m'a approché qui
m'a dit moi les gens en ont toujours ce
que je porte tout est en fait c'était
comme fait que je mette à se voit plus à
l'est par quelque chose comme la veille
et malin avec leur disque est un vrai
que le gaulliste un programmeur web
c'est également important la convention
d'actionnaires mon avocat psy psid cboe
pleut on s'entend post le nombre de
pourcentage à celui voulait que 55 ans
tu lui mets tes jambes argent mais
l'anti com - muller pour de quoi puis
moi je m'étais tu faisais tout le reste
et bâtisses équipe et ça me tombe
logistique pendant des mois je te dis
que ça va j'ai trouvé les achats le
porter tout s'appuyer comme cinq ans
pour sa reconstruction a décrit ce n'est
pas tant ce que j'ai fait mais je rex
avait fait plus jamais ce droit pis je
trouvais que ça faisait vraiment pas de
chance mais tai chi chi pour écraser
potentiel qu'elle m'a dit c'est du buzz
sur moi le genre marasme au témoin
monument est littéralement affecté
exemple la veille qu'on signe la
convention d'action je me rêvais ont
permis de l'année puis comme ce temps à
faire des films mais j'aurais m'avait
philippe bodard un mauvais feeling c'est
comme se terminer et je rentre dans le
groupe on a vu que j'en dis nous a
raconté comment son charmant duo bryant
poche on ne peut pas on peut poster ce
fait comme sinon qu'il est la convention
se meut ton parce que pour l'avoir fait
le processus est long pêchions qu'un
manque de négociations des conventions
en terminant pas le changer vraiment un
mauvais feeling ya possibilité conquest
était malade qu'elle qu'est ce que tu
fais le pote et ton mauvais si quoi
acheter quand mon fils est mort qu'on
pourra pas le même sens
la gastro et des malades quoi un filet
ou quoi de sega mais je veux pas la sni
tout vol à skis non mais le gréa rythme
gens risquent en fait pas on fait pour
c'est comme un défi que ok j'ai entendu
que finalement ça peut bien d'autant
peur qu est ce en vue du moment a fait
toute ma vie ta score un peu comme
j'avais avec toi d'agrément plus
justement sa bonne décision lundi
guy une question maintenant les oui
c'est quoi ton père parce que lui il ya
mis de l'argent non parce que là nous y
avait douze mois genre par tracts 2010
comme tous les pays du monde
les parents aussi
ça fait à peu près comme qui dit moi
quand j'avais comme en fait un enfant
taton a fallu que j'avais rencontré de
la propre et par du cabinet général
bernier vaillancourt a à québec et elle
le dit on est vraiment contents des
jeunes d'entre eux d'entreprendre avec
nous on comprend votre est actée j'y
pense qui est tombée c'est d'en
comprendre rien il m ils me disent et
moules positive à comprendre mais
finalement comme agent vol l'a pris
parce que c'est drôle parce que tu
arrives à la banque prend pas d'argent
pour ouvrir une compagnie ce temps que
j'avais pas de pandas pas mais cet
argent était tout dépensé pour acheter
cohésion qui en accompagne mixtape
partie des compagnies dans le rouge de
jeunes anglais ont un dirigeant sans
aucune connaissent aussi tiens t'es
jamais vu quelqu'un pas savoir ce qu
avec des antécédents vraiment brillant
comptabilité
[Rires]
pas de l'avant je me dis ma pratique une
médiation nîmes avait dû en effet
environ 200 marches pas le genre n'avait
rien à mettre en garantie tg revers
ayant un outil comme quand il dicte pas
d'actifs qui m'avait dit tu aurais tu
t'es vraiment quelque chose qu'on
pourrait s'y web puis j'avais bu la
seule chose de valeur que j'ai dans ma
vie à faire tel raymond à 53 ans et
maman des genres jamais je paye poche
terminator 5 pieds 2 pleine santé dans
le monde soit on a recommencé qu'est ce
qu'elle changerait tipi il ya des choses
changent dans hitman 15 mai le cas ceux
qui pillent marlins 60 ne sera même pas
aujourd'hui leur départ de feu ne pas
avoir d'argent même en partance avec
chaque scène que je dépensais savaient
exactement où ils allaient s'arrêter
foule importance acquis comme capitale
mais avant à recommencer je le ferai pas
de télé je me dis ok fans le ghost
épaules bongo c'est corey mais si je me
serai entouré de quelques uns qui a
piqué qui l'autre côté de martigues et
le côté plus gestion plus rigoureuse
aura match était plus jean louis loubet
up team et ont des stats des compagnies
déjà dans le rouge avec une première
expérience qui accéderait qui marche
moyen paie aussi ça chantait parents ont
fait toute leur vie qui ont fait
faillite
tt games de le faire quand même tu avais
pas genre on a peut-être que
l'entrepreneuriat un moment fait le
c'était vraiment naïve aussi parce que
quand tu sors daube et cache les
véhicules les gens qui aiment vraiment
gens vraiment moi j'étais comme les gens
m'aiment
ouais tout tout jeter 100 % pousse
vraiment pas compliqué demain sur mon
chandail la chaire jeu la machine où tu
l'achètes sur l'archipel fac parce que
je m'attends à ce que les compagnies
mais crible de faire de l'argent c'est
ça pour tout le monde qui veut tout le
monde qui veut exporter leurs tee-shirts
c'est pas simple mais testé sa
technologie je voudrais on avait craint
crohas et puis j'en avait récolté 15 mai
d'après ce courrier dans la
en 2015 ouvrir une boutique en ligne au
québec personne le cimt et les gros
joueurs avaient une présence web mais de
chez nous je vais avoir une boutique en
ligne de leur vous seul e cette époque
c'était pas c'était sorti de nulle part
c'était encore le genre mettant ma mère
l'est et comme il te fait confiance à
sauf quelque chose internet c'est est ce
que la terre était exagéré mais ta carte
de crédit c'est un terme et moi quand
j'ai appelé mon père pour lui dire que
je laissais ma job comme attachée de
presse adjointe du ministre l'éducation
est moche de rien
faudrait 60 milles par année à rennes 2
à 23 20 intro 24h je veux alors chez ma
job pour m'ouvrir une boutique en ligne
de dots accélérer son vieillissement
panache et puis ma fille non mais j'ai
fait moi j'ai froid j'ai marqué c'est
moi j'ai trois frappes plus violent un
schéma plus jeune chat seule fille gens
je fais caca de l'ordre je veux qu'ils
allaient le vertueux mais l'habitant ma
fille très à came into laisser mon sens
il ya même pas un terme au feuilleton où
c'est quoi ça la boutique en ligne de
vente mais il était gentil tu veux pas
c'est que pictet entrepreneur c'est ben
alors qu'ils soient des enfants sauf à
être fatigué mais il était finalement je
voulais vraiment le faire chiper sa
retraite qui avait juste sous leurs
formes wolfach primates et aide les gens
m'aiment puis j'en ai dit moi car j'ai
pas dit surpris le 5 juillet 2015 5 ou 6
juillet pense la boutique déjà composté
financer 100 me mais le ca marche et pau
petit dents cassées et des tags est
hachette saran tour - puis le ch vendait
ont tous besoin de nous ouvrir en mai en
rythme avec mon associé que j'avais pu
mais le ch t il faillait tout allait
refaire le site petit mathis est une
catastrophe le stoxx en pid et j'avais
plus tard c'était quoi la likouala
la ligne 2 de production le toit dans le
fond tu comment des avantages à ces
démarches sont enfin mon but c'était
comme comme sur la vente je donnerai
c'était cela la principaux trucks a été
pénalisé pour hachette 7 8 mois à
l'avancé ce pays au moment de la
réception de ton stade
et puis si ça mais le mois ça s'accumule
et c'est quand j'ai quand j'ouvre la
bouche et je suis vendu 2 10 chf
première semaine et st ours le stock
était couché dans mon condo dans mon 4
aux ennemis des boîtes des bateaux je
fais pas tu peux plus manger quelque
chose de cuit parce qu'il s'est absenté
deux vendu des tee shirts et mes amis
ont changé de nom c'est ça bézy pot
[Rires]
d'accueil d'enfants personne même
gentiva health ça me donnait sa dualité
tchèque de commequiers qui le budget des
le tout est tellement bien dormir six
semaines avait pas de vent pas sérieux
jean ce conseil sa personne mais j'ai
tellement et j'ai pas payer des cartes
de crédit germanophone à maman le petit
écran
faudrait vraiment qu'ils me prêtent de
l'argent ça c'est la conversation que
quelqu'un qui m'aime moi mettons je veux
jamais non mais c'est quoi ton martial à
pizza est rendu là était comme hakim on
a besoin de combien chez peugeot 206 en
percement notre pretty être comme moi
c'est moi je vais faire demain après
midi en allant tout magasin type de jeu
précieux deux mois maintenant parce que
j'ai recherché ma photographie j'ai pas
de gaz dans mon chat ta mort et en
tenant compte du conte avait gagné mais
non conservé dans le condo qu'on avait
le pendant une heure il était détruit
cinq ans du petit best-of condos flamand
neuf maisons et demi seulement cela
panier même pas une catastrophe mais y
était détruit le forez tester flambant
neuf mais les gens capables dès lors on
avait pris dans une agence de la casse
ont mérité une canne cole schaerbeek
mama la mère citée tout était
démoralisée abidjan
cette année le relais puis maryvette ou
vandalisées mon charme à battre jean a
répété j'avais fait douter de tout
allait mal en chutant à montréal
être seul j'avais un ami quand tu
commences en affaires on parle peu cela
mais jean les entreprend la solitude
c'est débile qui tout le temps que
finalement notre d'autres pensent que
j'entre roule sur l'or qui savent dans
une tente et voté qu'à ma droite
chandelle quelques j'arrive pour tree
c'est comme si ce test et c'était tout
un gros mélange de tous en même temps
qu'ils avaient été vraiment vraiment
rien au métier ou même offert ça fait
cinq ans j ai crisis pitt et je suis
vraiment pas gêné de le dire mais
j'entends marseille derrière c'est la
preuve pour dégager du profit
c'est gênant en mars 2020 c'est la
première fois que j'ai agi de profits
sur l'année financière au ccc fait peu
de piquant qui risque elle s'associé
ricains ça prend 5,1 mais ça pourrait
reprendre - de moi je pense qu'on star
qui était en effet de la tournée des
boutiques éphémères on a fait 9 pouces
et quand 12 montrealais québec c'est
encore des sinistres vauban laquelle
jean quand on roule à quatre ans que les
médias s'en feront d'arriver en ville de
bonn ya pas de cathy il n'y a pas de le
calculer ça et métiers j'ai pris des
victimes aux cowboys la société qui la
famille hoover gigue le côté très
terre-à-terre à ma mère qui est comme
genre tu mama pas cherche aujourd'hui le
savent et 25 en quatre ans même job et
arman est avec quatre bannières de
botanique star cherche mais un jeu dans
le mode en mode juillet est à quatre ans
avant d'intégrer la rivière du loup qui
a fait juste à côté très la malle
magique entre deux côtés vraiment qu'en
voyant mon corps mais pas si je serai
pas de vente aujourd'hui ce que je suis
si j'avais pris ce que j'avais mais
c'est une longue longue robe et moi je
suis chanceuse si je veux dire quand et
quand j'ai participé des six là j'avais
des gens qui me suivent et j'avais
chaîne sygic langue des gens qui m'ont
qui m'ont aidé et jetterait en
restauration j'ai dit si j'avais les
gants devant du condo m'avait dit d'être
déjà les 60000 d'air qui coordonne le
vent du thé aussi des ferries
transmanche pour rendre deux centimes et
tiji rembourser mes dettes d'études lui
rembourser pleine affaire intime en
reste et j'ai vécu sont ceux pour
pendant vraiment longtemps pour m'aider
à à six a imposé d'être ce qu'il aurait
fallu que je me présente il y avait
juste un prénom - associé ou que je me
rendais plus où katie
la vente de tee shirts comment tu as
fait pour tant la vie de sam et on sait
que des étapes à paris on pense pas ça
dans la vie ou pas c'est comme s'ils ne
m'attends genre j'ai peur c'est une
enfant mais c'est comme si une attente
dit c'est sûr que je vais m'arranger
dans villa prend en photos tableaux et
freddy pas de danger d'un milieu de la
longueur de noailles et une feuille de
soins non jugement on aurait dit que
c'était même pas que même encore
aujourd'hui puisqu'on prend des fois en
même temps moi j'ai pas beaucoup
d'orgueil puis j'ai pas d'ego le fait
que l'on m'attend si jamais je vois que
ça marche peu puisque je fais petit chat
marche pas on génère pas d'argent puis
je me plante vraiment je pense que
j'aurai capable prendre un site web apps
j'ai échoué ça ne fonctionne pas sauf
que je comprends les entrepreneurs aussi
qu'ils font peau parce que quand tu es
dedans c'est comme si la tâche et
émotivement vraiment rationnel au québec
objectivement si ça ne fonctionne pas je
tourne la page de fausi comme nageur
farhi souhaitons entreprises de mettre
un comptable à la tête
c'est xavier parce que les contacts sont
très faciles mais moi je parlais on
vient de changer de firmes comptables
puis-je ans et leur mère enfant j'ai
fait de toute ma vie le pont aven qui me
convainc qu'on pensait qu'ils étaient
bonnes puis j'en ai rêvé d'incarner ce
canyon depuis janvier tp hop le genre
game pis non mais contador faisaient les
prévisions plus je leur dis moi
maintenant ça s'est souvent fait non non
c'est tout le temps comme non mais le
tel un fat peut pas faire ça tu peux pas
faire ça tu vraiment mais c'est que
c'est guillaume 2-2 face son petit
speech hawking cow boy puis il te
plantes et solides puis blood hbo mais
tu peux être vraiment vraiment vraiment
très conservateur
mais en même temps je marche avec tout
ce que tout le monde me dit le thé
expertise en maintenant le au québec
dans ce temps si le pire cinq ans le 8
ou le monde commence à faire pas une
banque qui vient de prêter 10 où l'on
vienne en convainquent une pythie la fij
et repart avec elle le vendredi dernier
par mody et en rendre juste que tu
saches que non a décidé de vous a aidé
pigeant
arie haan a rien à saisir ses enfants
l'inventaire favori le web pour aux
autres au québec ne savons rien c'est
moi je m'appelle andaman company inc ou
le macbook jamais favori c'est pas notre
peau tu peux te pour une place dans ce
que l'on voulait l'en faire faire une
tendance venue à un actif pour avoir les
leviers financiers puis a pas une banque
et voulu me prêter pour l'actif encore
là parce qu'on a rien à saisir
même s'ils n'y prête pour ce qui était
encore le business woman maintenant chez
penske racing
une bâtisse à un million photos donnent
souvent dans les danses physique dans le
dans l'actif physx et 35% de mise de
fonds thema cet argent le gel mais tlo
ou jamais d'en acheter plus de stock
pour vente plus élevés puis aux états
unis tim moi je parle beaucoup beaucoup
en train de réviser les agences à
toronto puis un peu austère aussi les
autres sont comme un mets les banques
peuvent les écouter une lettre ça paiera
phares avant même si tu es mort de rites
vos titres tu génères des sous mais tu
t'attaches à rien c'est moi j'étais là
j'ai exigé savons avec quelle autre
plaie in the city brême s'est il montré
du jour je l'appelle mon asus eee pad
forme j'étais des fois des fois il
m'avait je réponds pas de texte à charge
répond c'est comme ça lui était déjà
adapté avec me disait t'es la banque qui
obtient ont accepté de nous aider
puis c'est vraiment koki aussi leur part
parce que cela gêne monde m'attend
demain je me dis-je on décide qu'on
ferme
il ya en reste - c'est parce que c'est
une des situations financières mais qui
lui est l'autre les groupes chinois sont
en train de monter la structure de pour
protéger les actifs
c'est correct je ne parle pas mais
disent tout et tout ce qui est en avance
puisque les problèmes deviennent de plus
en plus gros mois tu nous les
engagements ces six games qui met ces
sétois touaffeck j'imagine que la courbe
d'apprentissage est énorme dans une
business comme la tienne
coincé ou est ce qu'elle est c'est ça
grossistes et c'est devenu gros flip
l'heure c'est comme toutes ces nouvelles
affaires le cas d'aucune
c'est pas s pas question qu'ils ne
dévoilent agences moi je ne saisis pas
vraiment et j'ai pas le fait que je
comprends pas j'ai dit ce que je mange
compris l'analyse chez white est comme
ça devrait faire cesser tout bas je fais
ce que je te dis c'est la courbe est
énorme mais faut vraiment moi c'est le
plus gros conseil je te demande sait
s'entourer témoins l'année dernière en
janvier un peu compassé l'autre d'avant
mais des prix comme une directrice qui
était de 2 3 jours ce thème notamment
aidé à jarry développe le jeu vient d'y
offrir un job à temps plein en avant de
débuter comme moi ça voulait pas
vraiment parce qu'ils étaient caroit à
l'est des plaines business puisque veut
pas quand est tellement ne peut empêcher
c'est vraiment plus payant létale
interne puis jetée gens qu'on me dit
vous traitez comme voici mon salaire que
je donne xalapa qui m'était comme si
chez vraiment faire d'ombré à vendre
plus cher qu'un mot mais si moi j'ai jcj
moi c'est une stabilité mentale qui vaut
de l'or
c'était bien précieux pour vraiment
savoir s'entourer toulon vient d'engager
un acheteur était au début je trouvais
vraiment faux cul parce que plus engagés
de monde qui y arrivent en entrevue
tournage nash aux seniors en mangeant
cinq 5 ans d'expérience et la fia
sxminfo le plan arias o teich et quand
il se prend pour qui
ah parce qu'un fou enfin c'est mieux que
mourir s'il engage la gage pour cafasso
mieux que tout va bien à la jambe 42 ans
43 ans a fait toute sa vie c't'une king
pire c'est quand même dommage pour aider
ces deux équipes tout continue ici même
au départ mais en même temps on engage
membres sont vraiment plus compétents
que moi mais si fou comment capter
j'aurais pu faire ça avant lui ce parce
qu'on est on a le chiffre d'affaires
pour 100 m et 200 m était jamais j'avais
rencontré les open turgeon le lancer
président du conseil du commerce conseil
québécois du commerce au détail puis au
palm avait dit parce que chez pas le
jean chez m'a posé des questions sur un
an ferme et clairmarais doit messe à
trentels genre de personnes désormais 6
mendy pas les moyens de me payer sans
leurs affaires 80 nulle part
mais il ne faut pas tout le monde
c'était moyen tel pays foutu tellement
ou ce qu avatar mais cette personne
n'était mis souvent quand quand on est
en affaires on se dit ça va coûter à
votre ami ou après tout nous on est
comme six ans c'est un pronostic et du
sel à la presse que cette perte énorme
pour faire trois fois plus qu'au fait
que vous pour payer son salaire parce
que c'est folie que bell était sa mère
mais le fait que j'aie la banque sur de
mes enfants
mais si c'est si moi je prenais pas ses
décisions le jeu répond qu avant de le
faire mais le charme dans un point où
c'est dieu qui m'a si tu veux passer à
l'hôte et à pittsburgh mais tout
simplement parce qu'ils sont vouloir par
cette étape c'est juste de dire à qui ce
qu'on ne le sinar mas auxerre et nice
puis basse et six podiums est en émoi
tout cela est ce que maintenant tu es
rendu à un point où est ce que justement
dans tous les départements
nous mettons quelqu'un confiance qui est
là où tu en as encore beaucoup de
détours des toits - ben arafa et je te
dirai que tout ce qui est juste moi je
veux qu'ils vont pas beaucoup d achat
ticket com qu'est-ce qu'on fait comment
créer tous les âges hamilton ont créé
pas mal parce qu'on fait présentement
secte et ceci vraiment mais la chasse
commence de 15 kg moche comme dans le
fond j'ai vraiment à 15e bol je veux
faire quoi
la présidente rentrer tout le monde est
correct mais bon allez on va dire
c'est notre corps peut rien été c'est
vrai pis c'est drôle parce que c'est
quand même auteur de tranchant parce que
moi quand on me laisse du temps
ben gens c'est là que j'ai un cerveau
créatif et à 97% créative n'entreprendra
pas de star en moins drôle excès quand
tu me laisse du temps tu es comme l'on
travaille sur une compagnie de
cosmétiques depuis un an et demi c'est
un gigot meadow travail métier car au
stade de trancher manquant montre jamais
de garde de toute la fin de semaine moi
c'est comme géant profitera avant dans
trois journaux suisses et gardes se leva
situ par la ccit revient dans la soie je
travaille toute l'année c'est peu c'est
pas genre et s'est dit à faire des
petites conneries mais petit des fois
c'est comme l'eau douce comme aux
cubains dans une fin de semaine
j'ai créé un nouveau département complet
qu'on veut sortir chez owens avec toutes
les catégories produits qu'on va faire
d'être exhaustif mais moi je comme c'est
sûr quand arrive à un stade où tu peux
devenir moi je veux créer ce bain vous
mettez la en plastique c'est cher c'est
leur coin c'est vraiment et sauf que là
il ya eu guillou même si la compagnie
cosmétiques une autre compagnie soit que
je travaille davantage d'infos drake ça
c'est vrai à vos domaines piles de
papier basket se soit occupé
moi je suis très fier vraiment vraiment
très très très tard je prend pas des
décisions précipitées il faut tout le
temps que ce soit comme réfléchit c'est
moi j'ai même qu'un rôle car août est il
ya des codes que le clan des
entrepreneurs la pianiste une rouge
c'est comme gens sont vos fonds gaz au
fond on s'en fout de la route pour y
aller puis moi je suis fière des fois
jusqu'à toi tu calmes et j'en suis
vraiment c'est moi mais les employés au
bureau là toutes les ficelles important
et on peut le refaire puisque et 40 ans
amène jean moulin qui ont fait 40 ans a
même fait d'être dans mon c est bien
pour notre part ça c'est comme faut
briller une vie faut que vous vous en
vous aimez votre famille vos amis vos
défauts vraiment puis même si chaque
personne qu'on engage si foule
importante le site edge et parce que
dans le commerce au détail
là les gens qu'on engage sont plus
saignant sont pas
elle possède avant d'être là dedans et
sans régime de terreur c'est comme je
sais comme plus que tu travailles plus
que tes patrons terme dans beaucoup
d'entreprises jusqu'à plus de travail
que je trouve bizarre
ta vie et où jean mais sa seat on en
parlait autrefois quelqu'un qu'on s'est
vu le style la conciliation travail
social haggis métier c'est quelque chose
qui kaki tellement important mais
tellement négligez pas tellement c'est
quoi le contraire de valoriser des
valeurs comme dévalorisé concrètement
l'entrepreneuriat ouais c'est de
l'espèce de ting ting de dire c'est tout
le temps plus tout un travail est plus
tout le temps guen des plus forts tout
le temps pas plus d'argent mais c'est
pas sûr le tuer non c'est passé vite et
nous quand c'est drôle c'est qu'on a dit
au fait qui avait pas de faire plus que
40 heures semaine y en a qui ont
vraiment mal réagi en fait quand même
pourquoi chanter billetech com
je sais pas c'était une façon de montrer
qu'ils travaillaient fort mais je t'ai
comme pour moi ça fait pas de sens c'est
pour moi c'est comme témoin des faits le
monima demandant maintenant et je pense
qu'on en avait parlé un peu l'autre
pourquoi qui est maintenant je fais
c'est pourquoi je me suis partant dans
pharma c'est la raison pour laquelle je
fais pour mes amis ma famille et me
négligeant totalement montreux en suisse
n'est en rien d'avoir une business c'est
pour maud sûr si je le fais parce que
c'est cool pour eux si ça fonctionne
c'est moi quand je vois jean pezi à rien
affirmé marie-pierre mes amis qui
achètent toute sa boutique un code promo
diantre 30% de rabais
puis jean une capote qui sont en chasse
mais moi je fais ça pour ça chez soi
pour ses ouïes éventuellement plus que
ça avance plus ce qu'on fait souvent oui
je fais ce porte et un brin un bon
rythme de vie tu te faire des voyages de
pages estimé si j'ai pas des gens autour
de moi ça me sarah cohen haegel j'ai
fait de la fin même en forte et si vous
vous perdez tout les gens autour de vous
à cause de votre travail sape ans a fait
aucun aucun aucun sens et si je m'aime
j'explique ça carotti l'on entend on va
attendre visuelle intense chiffre
d'affaires cette année
pis comme stang c'est comme en faillite
gros ça se peut que ça soit 5 milliard
est obligé de faire l'année d'après on a
pu le faire parce que parce que tu es
groupe parce qu'entre temps le sac à
main
moi j'agis pas la fidh de la demande à
combien d'employés jusqu'en quelques
questions de merde on en a rien à [ __ ]
c'est déjà assez comme l'a toujours la
caisse sans quoi c'est le on en est tout
simplement début je n'achète pas un
handicap
vous êtes juste car c'est comme si
j'entends donc on peut être relié à ta
performance une boutique en ligne
mais martin ces questions le temps même
si on était sain ça fait une une
business heureux ça fait tout est un
endroit où c'est le fun de travail par
rapport avec ma grosseur d'entreprise
mais nous on essaie vraiment d'inculquer
son prénom nos employés ne sais pas si
ça c'est pas évident c'est ça c'est une
question qui me qui meurent qui m'habite
beaucoup le dit la limite mais ton de
jusqu'où est jusqu'où est ce qui m est
temps mais tant qu'on parle de savoir ce
qu'on est dans un monde capitaliste mais
jusqu'où est ce que moi je me rendrai
dans le sens où aujourd'hui il était
dans la vie que je mène je pourrais pas
mettons que tu me donnes 5000 de plus je
sais pas exactement qu'est ce que je
ferais différemment pour être ces pays
je lui promets que je trouverai des
façons le dépenser messas reid ce serait
juste de me crée des besoins ne tire pas
un sujet pas au petit je voudrais jouer
mes amis quand j'ai vu un jeu
confortable où est-ce que j'habite je
mange comme je ne peux me demander aux
restos quand ça me tente
on dirait que c'est se tait on dirait
qu'on dirait que moi je me vois vraiment
mal je vois vraiment mal qu'est ce que
je ferais plus que ce changement m'a
vite surtout il faut que sacrifie des
choses qui tiennent vraiment à coeur
pour pouvoir faire plus de commentaire
c'est un peu philosophique comme
casseurs médecins on vit juste une fois
puis si c'est juste pour travailler par
l'argent ça jean lessard à quoi s'était
déjà ajouté personne avec en profiter
mais moi je
je parle des solutions qui comptable à
saint-bernard puis ils m'ont dit et je
me dégage pas grosse arraché aux mines
depuis mon titre est l'argent dans ton
compte
je dois y sont comme on va baisser son
salaire si je me rends compte mais verte
est trop en gros ça va pour mon rythme
des budgets c'est sous quelques
chanceuses l'été je n'achète pas de
linge et l'on vote au resto et si j'y
suis c'est ce que vous même sapée monde
c'est la paix plein d'enfants tous les
avantages qui sont considérables maire a
raison
après ceci nous notons le montant
dépasse beaucoup d'un voyage de pêche
ans et plus ne sait plus à qui mais
c'est quoi ton l'on cherche l'intérêt
entre ce qui est déjà qu'ils ont été
ramenés à québec et à québec a fait
moins marquée au coin gens peu importe
le mélange pas les genres un peu un
salisienne de lauzon se borde la rivière
attenant est prêt comme nat somatiques
en dieu qui met gens peut-être que nos
maisons va t elle coûter cher parce
qu'ils étaient on venait à son terme un
grand terrain 120go dunk cours tant que
là on n'ait vu du bord de la rivière on
voudrait ça mais la technique des
friches en forme tout cas c'est comme
écouter c'est vrai qu'à ma réponse on en
parlait avant impute ammann est question
d'argent le type moi je me demande si je
suis petit je vous dis madame un
déguisement de milan 3 4 millions après
ceux où l'équation témoin mettons en ce
moment je comme péage et pas besoin de
plus mais je me disais un futur où
est-ce qu aimer ton du trou qui le place
très tôt eu des mots sans faire de
l'équitation se fendant même le sait non
ça devient compliqué pilote dans cette
équation le caecum équipe je suis jamais
besoin est ça vaut mais après ce cas tu
as besoin de souvenirs à des besoins une
vision faut que tu le fasses avant que
ça arrive c'est difficile d'arriver
d'impôts
dans les dents les débuts de home un
jour en retournant par l'arrière parce
que carla et moi si je me trompe
quand vous avez commandité mon iphone
année dos des mois c'est ce qui me once
amap pour moi j'imagine pour beaucoup de
monde
cette décision lorsque ça doit pas être
donnée de cette commandite club doit pas
être donnée cette décision laisse prend
comment quand un business qui débute
encore qui est encore à ses débuts que
tu dis ok go go avec ce avec ce qui est
un move énorme webmaster c'était
vraiment cowboys métier là la commandite
de dating on n'avait même pas l'est pour
faire 6 cas une catastrophe le tice qui
nous demandait en termes de vêtements
c'était tu es parce qu on est en
inventant sur le web
mais même en échange de produits mais
tant qu'on enlève l'argent de semaine en
produisent des parce qu'il fallait
non non mais je voulais autant voulu
fêter ses dix ans maintenant le nombre
de filles je suis payé 7 à 8 fille belle
porte pas toutes les grandes appareils
de s'habiller tout le monde le sait nous
dans ça c'est aujourd'hui demain réd
commandites ou des manifs y serait bien
mais pas top l'accepter et pauvres est
ce qu'un effet rien ne me laisse pas nés
lors on livre des pertes de 278 me
faisait la tournée des boutiques
éphémères en même temps une catastrophe
dans la nuit mais en pierre camatte
continue c'est ça c'est seulement la
question en fait c'est plus tôt quand tu
sais que tu saches un point je dis ça va
payer
dans trois ans mais en fait tu sais pas
sauf que maintenant dans leur camp qui
t'ont faisait la tournée des boutiques
éphémères et l'opportunité daudet
j'avais déjà le brûlant le tordeur
affecté comme rendu le pit t on a été
dans le pire des cas qu'est ce qui peut
arriver
l'enfant dont le père paix rhdp repaire
des cols c'est que ces êtres humains je
m'attends maintenant coeur mais dans le
pire des cas c'est un petit domaine ma
tante et y avait peu j'avais pas dit si
j'avais on a viennent d'être le langage
une des deux comme cent mille le chez
desjardins quand on perd 10 comme ça
mais cette époque c'était pas un million
le thé je n'avais pas ma vie à quelqu'un
je me donne moi ton calme appelant plus
en plus de familles je l'emprunté sur un
n en était rien n'a encore bougé
rembourser comme but immédiat ce par
mostefa l'est vraiment que ça sorte mais
s'il me dit on va juste vendre le stock
m'en restait one love stocks et de
l'argent qui va rentrer et on va en
perdre parce qu'il nous dépensons
beaucoup trop élevé pour leurs revenus
qu'on fait mais c'est dans le pire des
colosses caisse a fait c'est que quand
les revenus de la tournée des boutiques
éphémères puisqu'elle est et audi qui
terminait ben genre je pense qu'on on y
tombe à deux employés j'arrête
honnêtement j'ai dit tout le monde je
suis mis en avant mais là on est au
parti d'un modèle latin des petits qui
fait mal la raison dans la fête et
clermont ne voulais pas choquer mais
grandeur des deux mois qu'ils aient voté
dans le fond tout c'était à rimouski
sont en victime et son mon site moral
est bon ajoute qu'il est allé même temps
mais plus que ça avance et plus que
c'est devenu trop au début on pratique
un sprinter à fond louer des salles spip
à l'arrêt tout pesé non bio feuille de
route et joseph terence bout puis le
tout cas ce temps-là gatineau lieu avec
ton truc le têt enquête langage poétique
n engagent ni ta petite faute il faut
que ton staff il faut que tu dois jetons
staff août nourrissent déjà ça et en
protides des requêtes se faire par
l'acte et d'en faire comme a finalement
on n'y va pas en inventer de dante apple
soit avance bien a dit que c'est même
pas une question mais ça n'a jamais
passé par la tête
on va re être jamais tu t'étais très
c'était du genre tu bill d'études
l'espèce de noms passés en tête dans le
gens sérieux c'est drôle papier lorsque
ben c'est sûr c'est un entre deux
personnalités que tout accord ce que moi
je sais pour un fait que je me réveille
la nuit le spin rim
oui mais en fait la spin tout le temps
mais thé à la menthe et comme moi
j'avais quand même je croyais vraiment
en moi je me dis c'est qu'on va en
finale
l'alt horrible ce qui fait mal ça n'a
pas fonctionné péter wyss a fool
fonctionner parce qu'ils étaient comme
tu as fait aux dépens des comme cbx
business lunch saper sa tribu où tout le
monde est confiant ça c'est des steps to
business dans mci fait faillite et
comment ça marchait pas très présente ça
marche et foule mais moi je pense
tellement de monde parce qu'on voulait
dix minutes je dois pas pu reporter les
exécutions pitié je continuais là-dedans
piquant que le on est revenue et le
conte a congédié le monde
piketty a été jean ça a été tu offres
je me rappelle comment s'est elle mange
en dansant le pij avait promis ma vie le
piste est comme mon tomtom go chief la
havane face à médecins de terrain il a
fait génie financier pitt est comme ça
fonctionne c'est comme ça on dit chez
comme je m'étais dit je vais me la sorne
après ce pour laisser retomber ce qu'on
vient de faire le tri le récolte tech
leur récolte en un peu le fruit de
meetic antique un peu quand j'ai dit
tout le monde cela que des dépenses de
ce lac tout bâti ça ça vient à se
balancer tranquillement quitté se cacher
quand même bien entouré le timon agences
avec lesquelles israël il m'avait garçon
serait encore avec eux fait qu'il en a
fait une refonte du site mais termine
mon équipe et iso gens si c'est moi
aussi comme dirait qu'il en est allé
voir le monde on n'avait jamais de
demander au web 100 % de ce que le web
pouvait nous donner ce qu'elle envoie
revenait plomberont va se confier sur le
web on veut vraiment comme mettre toute
notre énergie là dedans ciblées sont
noués en deux mais j'étais encore dans
le 5 1 un trouble et je me disais ok qui
nous sépare des autres 31 mars le je
pense que c'est une quatrième grosse
année financière complète de la taille
d'une 31 mars psychique il ya encore du
gaz allait chercher d'autres 7eme oui
c'est eux m'écarter d'antichrist quand
tu es dedans on aurait dit que tu vois
moi un peu l'air la perte nette est en
train de juristes on peut dire mais il
faut savoir aussi remanié par contre moi
j'avais perdu seul autre année d'après
ge avait descendu comme un genre une
perte de 90 milles au livre le tarn et
ont traversé le poupon originaire
on a commencé à générer du profit fait
que tu as à voir mais c'est sûr que si
deux en perte de -1 pt surtout que s'ils
apprennent business l'action commence ce
sont des histoires depuis dix ans petit
film était mauquenchy seul à l'aubade
pts tu veux moi je vais aller emprunter
à bon marché
ça me prend deux années de pause d'été
financiers dans le positif c'est quand
même beau village près même pas
m'acheter un dimanche et anglet
raccordement sur foot national
jamas une laveuse sécheuse par un
président pour la compagnie comme tu es
tu comptes chèques pour accorder cet été
[Rires]
c'est un apprentissage qui était je me
rappelle amman et jacky j'avais
rencontré personne qui remet à faire 3 4
x 2 d'acheter la compagnie ou d'acheter
les parts de scpi un ami je voulais
vraiment quelqu'un achète une partie de
la compagnie mais il faut quelqu'un me
sortent la tête de l'eau gens vraiment
pige avant ça n'avait pas marché bien
plus maman puis j'étais couché a
tendance à des vaincus ma mère de la
petite reine
c'est une douceur incarnée camaret dit
c'était pour breuil à chaque fois que
quelqu'un dit non arrête parce que
j'avais jamais à être marrant c'est que
d'autres c'était pour brailler le ça est
très longtemps quel genre d gândul etc
et finalement faire ce qui est un bon
conseil ce qui est bien un conseil or
tout le plan des différents devant le
médecin qui change de job parquet cette
audace d'autoriser mentir non sens a été
la télé les derniers temps et toutes les
banques le teint après l'autre jean
après l'autre à rien savoir
il ya une personne qui viendrait des
piges en lieu une banque qui a décidé de
nous aider plus et rate et d'épicés
c'est quand à ses trois filles étaient
sold aussi parce que moi j'ai juste part
à des hommes qui vivent dans ces camps
mais tu dis c'est certainement pas connu
il ya deux banques sont allés jusqu'à
fin piste est juste des filles les deux
banques m'inquiétais comme nous on croit
en toi nous en voyage je pense que tu
penses que la vie
encore la société caméléon est ce que
les gueux voit une femme entrepreneur si
son nom selon certains moi j'suis ko
début je le pensais paul jusqu'à temps
que le jarry dans une jambe de badauds
de deux banques qui que l'on commence à
générer de l'argent avec son homologue
puisque les deux banques ces deux femmes
qui sont comme qui sont son monde aussi
pichan le changement tant le changement
aux gens des questions tu es money bank
moment dimon sait où ils sont mais il
m'attend pourquoi mais ça me prend des
tons gris culte été voir maintenant les
expériences de travail des développeurs
pour être capable d'avoir cette campagne
aujourd'hui c'est le taux d'expansion
vraiment fait bonne impression jeudi mis
en jambes il est arrivé des questions
caisse comme à des enfants c'est-à-dire
enfants ça va faire quoi qui va
s'occuper de la compagnie des gens
aujourd'hui on attend on a tendance à
oublier mettons les banques mais au
final ce qui s'occupe des dossiers c'est
des individus lé service en régie par de
quoi au dessus qu'il faut que formaté
mais au final la décision est pris par
quelqu'un qui fuit vers man est comme ça
alors quelqu'un parle parce que tu es
mauvais temps là puis j'ai pas beaucoup
de fils tu l'as fait que j'arrivais que
j'en mets valeur imminente aspect temps
semblé jeter comme faut que vous parler
parce que c'est mieux quand que tu nous
on a monté sa remise en fait à 15 alors
dollars c'est ça la rentrée pour tout le
monde et on a dit de le faire comme ça
parce qu'on est capable de le faire mais
on est et on veut le faire
je pense que c'est la moindre des choses
c'est le 15e rang de l'or le saman les
chauds puis de l'autre bord tu étais
comme médiatiquement un format 10 à 13
ans à 15 soit pas trop moi je suis dans
le monde parce qu'on est capable de le
faire mais quand j'arrive à la banque 4
mai et à financer puis 4 août qu'elle
génère pas assez de profits faut que
vous vous parler parce que moi si tu
veux que je n'en a plus de profits faut
que je co paquet pas bien naturellement
la première partie ce qu'on est capable
de couper dans les salaires de nos
employés musulmans d'être encore plus
profitable il faut quelques paillettes
par mètre pour me demander de petits
moyens et d une banque qui est une mise
de finances et puis il m'a dit tu vas
nous employer à l'entrepôt entre à 14
heures de l'heure mais sans lui nous
avons grandi plus beaux sites pour elle
descend chercher quand c'est faux le jeu
mais c'est parce qu'elle est maintenant
tellement de la profitabilité que c'est
sûr
certains qui est question qui va en écho
pays puis après ce qu'un coup petite
descente au loyer essayé de descendre
tels que la farce c'est sûr que ça va t
en prime et en principe si c'est tout le
temps comme un gros glitch de kif heinz
et owen va encourager les entreprises
québécoises mais pourtant que ça parce
que tu es dans le commerce au détail qui
fait doublon comprend rien et puis le si
jamais tu quand on va faire quoi avec
toi tu sais quand même sur des pentes
quoique moi je dirais que la bd se
voulait pas m'aider aux dépens de quoi
gens dépendants ma cliente est à paris
chez nous picard typiquement le terme de
droit devraient aider c'est parce que
nous on répond pas à la demande on n'est
pas capable d'abord assez de stock pour
le stock qui viennent sont quand même en
circuit mois la vendre aux jeunes des
dépôts de 40% tu étais le calcul de
manille ok ok j'étais quant aux dépens
de quoi jean au détroit avait été dans
le fond c'est trop risqué aux dépenses
courantes et est une banque canadienne
ont des parcours des parkas maquillant
tard arrive chez notre 4e stage dans la
cave
penses tu vraiment qu'à veulent
l'acheter sur un autre site qui est
basée au québec qui génère de la taxe
qui engage du monde qui payent l'impôt
ces gens de petite pause en question
dépend de quoi parce que c'est une
boutique en ligne
c'est sûr que ça serait cool c'est quand
qu'on tape sur google boutique en ligne
de vêtements que google te sortent juste
autour de toi sois pris avec le canada
tu peux acheter aux états mais ce polar
et allemand c'est aux dépens de le coma
et des scieries ce qui met aux dépens de
quoi te moques âge cheikh le nombre de
cartons à gênés rentrer au moins jusqu
au messti je fais ma porte je ne mange
pas imiter le luron et je payais pas
encore d'impôts parce qu'il avait généré
maintenant on va payer comptant des
employés disent ils en furent une vision
comptable de typhus baisser leur salaire
baisser en bout de ligne c'est à
ressource la plus précieuse des employés
peuvent attirer du monde exceptionnelle
on engage des filles des aveyronnais qui
va changer et six notes top boys et
quand on veut giovanni commune entre
paul sans farce je suis debout mais on
reçoit jean 70 cl venir faire des boîtes
et les gens veulent participer
après ça quand on a commencé à engager
pour langage chez paulette 18 19 20 21
logements star ça avec mon agent qui a
obligé d'y faut faut faire plus que ce
pour réseaux secs l'éviter comme mais
qu'est ce que j'ai dis le moi je
m'achetais je te préviens times à 12 ans
pays qu'est ce qu'ils aimeraient avoir
qui pourrait comme tout livré à matignon
à savoir deux contre deux journées de
congé flottante de plus par année de ce
qui est déjà prise par la loi joueur qui
était bon on leur donnait appréciera
tout dans les assurances collectives en
plus cher une post crise la france
collective fait chier comme ça mais on
ne rentre au régime d'assurance
collective présent prêt à temps plein il
s'agirait d'une part inquiet parce que
tu es mon enfant j'ai peint une scène de
copé j'ai rien dans mes rêves j'ai 30
ans c'est ok fine du temps à faire mais
réalise on m'a baisé nice mais je peux
me paraît m'ont pas mal éduqués m'ont
même pas appris qu'il fallait je mets de
l'argent la mairie n'ont pas appris ces
enfants leur fait que j'ai dit comment
qu'on pourrait effectuer au moins vous
venez d'être un média qui tourne et
oriente quand même pour rien et il ya
des cotisations réinvente les business
peut fermer ton employé même largement
serre est un parfait petit peu mieux
jean 57 dans gaza ce qui met en
concurrence de 3 % par année mais c'est
comme ça c'est un régime d'apartheid de
profils gens nient tout business font
pas se jeter comme innovâtes on va le
faire
exc le les filles on en est un gars qui
va venir de l'information sur
l'importance des mets de l'argent que tu
sois obligé de la suite tournait comme
tu es désolé ils ont engagement doublé
on est obligé pigeant c'est cool puis
tout s'achète même carte de l'intérieur
moi je mets 5 en scène de jean romain de
mes 50 ans dans tera peu après deux des
hommes un peu partout
ton argenté problème qui reste le 2 en
même temps ça c'est la règle de base
pitt et moi maintenant le genre je
trouve ça vraiment important d'aider des
eaux dans un litige de j'habite dans
notre fresque danser j'osais je passe à
côté du président jublin de changement
gzp de lasagnes sotchi muscle à sa
charpente en bois dont les engageront
leur dit vous êtes obligés d'aller faire
au moins une journée de bénévolat par
année payer si vous voulez payer ou
d'opter pour la femme
on les oblige à participer à ce genre
d'affaires la pitié ils sont pauvres
ça participe tellement
au sentiment d'appartenance puis à
l'idée de vouloir traire et tout moment
sans même direction utilise ces sur le c
sur puis ces décisions là qui sont dans
une pme qui sont somme toute assez
marginal au sens si tu paies en employés
une journée pour aller faire du
bénévolat c'est pas ça qui va mettre
dans le puits après si tu regardes
mettons pour des multinationales qui
kiffent qu'ils les employés veulent se
syndiquer pour augmenter leur salaire
d'une pièce qui l'est c'est comme on
l'aimé tout à la porte parce que
fonctions parce que c'est trop d'argent
ça remet vraiment perspective là la
relation avec on dirait le gain infiniti
puis comme on dit tantôt c'est quoi qui
est important au final les moyens sauf
qu'il est important à fond
sauf que terme à tous ces entreprises
qui agissent comme ceux à un certain
point je les comprends quand les
institutions financières sont aussi
demandant s'il ya quelque chose qui fait
que la roue à taureaux et moi je fais
des bourses de 2 kg on s'est fait dire
ça pourrait être mieux inciter comme
c'est moi les instants financièrement
des matons forêt qui montera valeur
d'inventaire faudrait que tu ailles plus
d'actifs puis plus d'engagement
financier à ces courses que tu me
demande de faire c'est les trois
critères pour quoi que les gens dans mon
domaine font faille
je veux que je retourne là dedans c'est
comme le com puisque la demande est
vraiment la demande de performance est
vraiment grand ici se dire que c'est moi
les trucs que j'ai mis en place si je
vais faire puis au début je me disais
tout le temps à ce sport on peut pas
faire ça on est bien trop petit en
régime de quatre façons la victime était
ya pas de était même trop petit mais ça
fait partie de mes valeurs refuge dans
les forges à dimanche afin dé repos va
enfin parce que je leur donne tout mon
argent tijd herman et va falloir plus de
monde sur mandrichi très confus m'a dit
comme je sais comment vont bon train
tout le monde
on s'en doutait déjà mené à qui il veut
comme un peu plus oiseaux migrateurs
parce que tous nos publics est il si
tout le temps des demandes de partout
piger dans leurs avions n'étaient quant
à l'effort dé s'allonge pour les
itinérants des bâtards en fait 80 watts
à linge pendant une semaine pour des
itinérants craint l'effet au bureau tu
as vu dans la
vu les gens participent à un projet vu
monter un éclairant et sur saint joseph
a rédigé un bon tampon jambes ont essayé
[Rires]
mais je n'avais pas parce que s'ériger
je le fais parce pense égoïsme à ça me
fait plus plaisir d'aider le monde qui
est que les gens que les vins doux 20 21
un bonheur infini ccal dernièrement de
participer aussi avec le truc de la
primauté donnée dans le fonds pour les
restaurants c'était quoi ce n'est
exactement
bon en fait je me sens comme peu mal de
là mais jusqu'à non je vais t'expliquer
l'agent vraiment pitié 6 grièvement a
peu compté contre les villes je ne peux
pas les conduit quoi que ce soit mais tu
es à d'autres parties face aux états
unis sans vraiment bien fonctionné du
mans quand il entend jamais jamais
devoir d'appliquer ou est impactée
d'après abc
je pars super mais aussi médecins non
mais moi j'ai fais ce que tu es ou même
évidemment voter en personne
mon argent - si j'ai envie de vendre des
bateaux avant des bateaux déjà levé bun
b - quelle est la pdg par l'attaquant
commander des bateaux on vend des bâtons
sur le site des photos en bikini sur des
bâtons mais ce pôle hippique nicosie
entre que finalement tu me traites ou
cali face au québec sont invités comme
support à radio-québec laon ils veulent
tellement genre isis qui va la vie mais
finalement ils veulent peut-on mdt
géante que moi je veux juste qu'elle
sache que si tu le fais jambart commun
fait remarquer sophie gens comme trou de
trois jours après il décide d'embarquer
jusqu'à monter on va donner 1000 dollars
en dépit mille dollars pour ouvrir le et
je pense que si ce que je dépensais d'un
resto à un mois des fois les gens
malades ou resto le bas mais le bias a
valu tintamarre bague - bigeard timone à
toutes vos questions ici comme lien peu
d'argon pull et seconde pige comme tony
restaurant convient d'encourager tout
d'abord puis aux stocks java dans l'ailé
moi j'agis comme georges devient il pas
ses mots tube i come on mais on va
prendre si besoin on va prendre de
comprendre une bonne de la maintenance
et le cadre à shaker aussi justin
dollars le pauvre et c6 et je me dis pas
exagérer c'est bien pu piquer tous les
gamins quand vous parlez puis après si
on leur parle et qui avait raison de
dire comme il ya jean 14000 personnes
qui ont dit oui qui veulent contribuer
quel genre 200 personnes qui ont des
hopis mais quand une mais pop c'est pas
pour me reprocher mais c'est embêtant à
d'autres enfants
je pense qu'il le peut être parce que
les gens le demandent et puissant comme
le monde embarque effectuant ce poster
son chauffeur de garde ont pu mais nous
allons rarement se défoncera abouti pour
des andes
c'est la preuve que ça va le donner pour
aider à chaque comme trois mois en
prenant regagner sa part à la fièvre en
fait moisson québec on a récolté 20
mille dollars un mois c'était fou c'est
comme langue en fait pour le pignon bleu
qui comme le type de projet de la ville
de québec on commence vraiment beaucoup
moins donc on a avancé mais c'est ce qui
a pignon bleu puis moisson québec de
l'humain monde et je redis que lui dicte
des jeunes et ça aurait vraiment et
c'est comme d'incompréhension messier
gens donnent faut vraiment d'inspiration
enfants n'ont pas fauté sensibilise pis
si je pense que j'ai dit
c'était pas ça [ __ ] même temps je me
dis non à donner et puis en tout cas je
veux voir avec lui ou thé partout de
mettre ses poches non quelqu'un sauf
qu'il y avait un peu raison c'est vrai
que des fois les gens font qu'à droite
c'est bon jean bart et le disent et
khâgne 40000 personnes qui ont soirée
pop puis genre 250 dont six se perd même
quand tu te dis pas tout le monde qui
est moynier d'honneur d'enfance peu
comme ce qu'on brasse tout sauf que nous
on voit quand on veut aider une cause
c'est des fois oui c'est en
sensibilisation de dota modo on a mis la
patronne de noms sur le site nous quand
ils donnent sur le site ont fait une
scène la limite nous on paye les frais à
chaque fois nous donne par jean chapet
fait part en dessous le texte mais on le
fait pas ce qu'on veut on ne trouvait à
travers la tant que les gens veulent
aider les gens mais ils savent pas
comment le faire d ici six corps et
quelques unes pillon le pignon bleu
iphone 4 fois mais support informatique
pour faire des dons ne vont pas se payer
un site web la grèce d'une pièce
christophe est né comme on va le faire
mais tu es si c'est quand ça marche tout
comme souvent ce qu'ils apportent de
tout ça parle t'on preuve finale fonte
des effectifs je suis toujours seule non
il faut que je sois prêt à oui c'est ce
faut que tu sois prêt à prendre cette
direction et tous - ouais si l on vient
me reprocher j'ai pas fait assez de
profits parce que j'étais déjà déprimé
par un mode la préfet le profit quel est
le pourcentage le rend pas plus heureux
en fin de la journée c'est sûr que ça
monte un indice de kifaya ça marche
c'est soulageant mais c'est après cet
échec cet argent lui il y aura
certainement pas nous reprocher d'avoir
été de monde c'est vraiment une vision
rafraîchissante on dirait le temps de
parler de tout seul puis me rappelle
c'était l'une des raisons c'est pourquoi
je voulais inviter ce parce qu'ils me
mettant dans le parcours
d'entrepreneuriat que nous on a décidé
de concilier oui on veut que ça
fonctionne mais aussi on veut tu es la
meilleure façon qu'on peut
que tout le monde soit bien et tout le
monde est heureux que ça amène le plus
de deux trucs positifs puis que dans la
tige dépendant de prendre des actions je
demandais si on le fait ici avec des bdd
prix on en parlera après au prix leméac
des prix pour certaines portaient pas de
casque qui ont fait citer pour essayer
de donner une tribune à des gens qui
peuvent pas nécessairement le fortifie
même si des décisions qui business wire
font pas beaucoup de sens laitiers pour
la france
mais comme d'avoir cet hymne kings qui
est pas basé purement sur la rentabilité
on dirait que c'est ce genre de
d'entrepreneuriat puis de capitalisme
derrière lequel je peux peuvent
inquiéter
ouais mais tant le capitalisme sauvage
de dire le genre argent tout prix me
tuer je revends nestea au détriment de
l'environnement mais je vais en vendant
tabarnak tpiy ce c'est comme on dirait
qu'on dirait que j'ai de la misère à bac
s e puis de l'autre côté
la mesure a bâti un système socialiste
qui colle mal inverse que de séoul a
coincé ou qu'on se batte type comment
qu'on fait pour collectivement sortir de
mettons-les les enjeux sociaux mais
aussi les enjeux environnementaux comme
un conte faire sortir de terre en
utilisant le 6 le seul système de
l'humanité qui est prouvée qui marche
est à dire le capitalisme mais c'est un
peu de mal on dirait mais c'est une
question de valeurs des messages à 105
dans ce sens où comme moi ce que je suis
je ne dis pas qu'il faut que ce soit
comme ça mais c'est pas ça fait partie
de mon été je veux dire moi je me suis
même temps que je me suis dit aïe faut
qu on donne tout les tampons qui savent
être sympa gratuit au bureau comme un
pick up
mais j'ai comme typiques du pays gotti
three qui m'ont dit jean-jacques pas
pour mes visites ses employés qui valut
sa combi de dollars par mois
[Rires]
je vais très bonnes questions de genre
combien ça coûte une question de temps
était vraiment moi je suis tout un défi
en 2008 arrive à john tobin tombe pas
passer ton temps porter je sais juste
d'enlever ça mais c'est des trucs que
c'est une question de baraf des zones
moi j'aimerais avoir quoi après ceci
sauf que si facile d'avoir une les
employés sont super nes chansons sont
vraiment utile ça ça se peut qu'on tombe
sur des gens qui soient pas nice pitcher
la manette c'est un ensemble des gens
qui abusent source
c'est ce que tu es gentil il est pote on
n'a pas toutes des belles les courses où
justement tous tp bien plus d'une bonne
condition pour garder ton monde
tous ceux qui ont le goût de travailler
puis on le goûte simple type sont
contents d'être là qui sont engagés ces
spéciales mais dans notre cas pas
remboursés c'est quoi tes valeurs c'est
pas ça fait vraiment partie de tous
après ce qui suit pas les mêmes valeurs
pis ces six artistes mais t'es sûr
qu'elle soit en partant tu sais pas en
partant que c'est exactement ça fait
valoir un peu partie de ses médecins
après ccc sortant grosse amman et moi je
vais perdre le contrôle de ses enfants
de ses mets toi même temps tu veux tu
éviter de grosses heures au point où
est-ce que tu parles contrôle sur la
forme je sais pas je sais pas le c'est
sûr que la pandémie a amené son lot de
tinhou la pandémie on la vivait depuis
janvier dernier parce que toutes nos
manifs acteurs ont fermé en asie fait
qu'on ait vraiment on est passés
gentilles en tchéquie par contre on sait
que notre vie comme un compte en ligne
et plus long checker les schémas et
ramon des communautés ont été fermées
dans le faux gentil c'est comme on
n'avait plus rien à vendre on travaille
pour les branchés mais le ca a mené si
nous on explose faisant exploser les
explosifs une édition cowboys comme ça
n'avait pas de bon sens il fallait deux
autres entrepôts de style comme saint
anne et jean avec le c'est sûr qu'elle
génère plus de sous on commence à faire
un profit qui est intéressante chose
qu'on faisait pas avant il était comme
ma marotte sa mère enfant et été
claudia qui mais là on va voir cette
année comment ça va aller mais je pense
que si tu t'entoures de du monde et je
pense pas que qui en raison que ces
valeurs ne disparaissent parce que plus
qui est en avance sur notre temps dont
ceux fournis verticalement fabrique tout
son convent métier on travaille des
importateurs on s'assure sur des normes
d'éthique de quelques unes aux
travailleurs t as tort en asie
principalement où met-on je sais pas
exactement sa chance y est différente
chaque fournisseur la laine est en place
et chaque truc est différent mais telle
on travaille avec des gens notariaux
outils qui font comme un peu plus comme
ce champ magnétique est si petit peu
plus d'assurer que sa suite fait que je
me dis chez poste à quel point que ça le
serait plus utile on travaille t notes
et même la ligne de cosmétiques donne
vraiment 19 heures
chapeauté par oman souffert d'un bon
départ explosif
cette poule je vous ai trouvé ce cas ce
métier finalement et plus que ça chemine
puisque c'était comme impossible quelque
chose de bon en fait c'est plus que je
veux pas que les gens pensent que c'est
comme un attentat richie même si le bas
de caisse une lipstick france passerait
si nous ça fait un an et demi qu'on
travaille là ton travail des
laboratoires auront thériault a ici à
montréal un peu partout en fait si je
pensais qu'avec l'iphone c'est sûr que
c'est tellement compliqué pis j'en
oublie cela au début je comprenais pas
de personnaliser maintenant on est dans
le morbihan c'est we too expensive le
tout le monde soupçonnait d'être là
parce que je ne puis plus qu'à avancer
si ça c'est parce que c'est devenu je
voulais pas que les gens pensent que
c'est un crime été dépeinte comme un pis
vous même c'est une propriété
intellectuelle une marque de commerce au
canada et aux états-unis effectifs y
mettant le cosmétique c'est vraiment peu
le même style que l'on mène ce fake en
attente chez pas ancrée temps de
produits place à lèvres puis jusqu'à
l'iss voici une le grand barça l'haridon
veulent l'acheter mais ça ça qu'à
lui-même
c'était comme pris avec le nom des prêts
que l'amalgamé fait des conflits de la
marque de commerce pour l'avoir fait
aussi ceux ci n'ont cauchemar c'est avec
moi j'ai fait renoncer puis c'est
vraiment deux business et deux façons de
fois ces deux images de marx et de trucs
complètement différent c'est que tu es
comme le mans toute l'équipe de vaud
même sens et par alcan
départ de la manif ça me tentait plus ça
m'excite pu jeter quand whc de la marque
sea shepherd derniers temps leur travail
sur la marque de commerce sont là non
plus le genre survenu quand ça doit être
vraiment difficile de concurrencer au
niveau des prix avec avec les grosses
compagnies multinationales de ses quatre
titres et même dans le vêtement s'est
dit si c'est parce que tu es là nous
depuis qu'on sonne et verticalement
c'est sûr que notre augmenter parce que
ton travail des gens me regardent si
c'est comme un autre façon de faire sauf
que c'est ça nous permet vraiment
contrôler plus la qualité de ce qu'on
fait là façon c'est fait et à tous les
niveaux c'est beaucoup plus sécurisant
mais attire nos missions qui nous ont
dit on va s'y rend trop chère thème pour
moi je peux plus me permettre ce métier
je n'ai pas de réponse enfants on peut
peut ça pourrait pas que mon chat ça
pour être plus tard évidemment après
ceux de ce compte d'autres choses sont
libres de jours ouvrables partant québec
tant au québec qu'en ontario forte
hausse entre 50 et 7 jours sur 7 et 1 1
comme on t'offre ce que ça vaut ensemble
ou mais après ce t il comme mj beaucoup
des reportages tchèque des affaires
pitié m'attache à crier que telle ou
telle compagnie telle part de marché de
masse commis nous allemands sous la
porte de marché dans des trucs aux 1
j'espère qu'ils trouvent ça n'arrête
après cependant game de vie fait
référence
mais chacun je m'en rende compte faut
vraiment que tu arrêtes de mettre en
attente et pendant des mois c'est
pourquoi comme témoin je commence à te
quitte ta joie de voir ta joie puisque
je me suis pas assez de commentaires
hier et jusqu'à ce que tu vois
clairement que ça à feuilles ces genres
des couleurs et des carrés de couleur
bleue c'est juste comme tout bon
pourquoi un portage points le tout mais
moi je m'en étais pas rendu compte mais
le jugement contre les dfa de les voir
mettez en même temps l'espionnage
industriel
je me rends compte que je pense que
l'oms et c'est une possibilité mais je
pense que apprend de plus en plus sa
place s'il rentrait avec plein
importateurs plourde chacun je convoque
a pas plus avant que nous écrivent
qu'ils apportent dit on et nicolas
demain at je pense qu'elle monde savent
peau je pense qu'elle n'attend le commun
des mortels pense que ton retour des
millions je pense que l'industrie
pensent que tu fais rien
mais en fait c'est comme un conte de
fées sont ici comme on commence à mais
on fait juste du web aussi une technique
qui nous ont juste au québec francophone
on est chanceux d'avoir devant autant
qu'ils veulent francophone t il ya un
gars qui m'a écrit leurs sportifs jean
bringer mr un grand groupe de tous nos
employés
c'est un objectif et d'explosifs moi je
cherchais les colis chez vous jean trois
fois quatre fois par semaine puis le
lendemain c'est moi qui les ai dit même
des clientes le temps ville de québec il
y reçoit aura besoin le leur mais manqué
qui ont commandé j'en ai moins besoin de
laver faire et de céder bilger maison
fait partie de votre business
angie jamais vu parce que j'ai jamais vu
autant de colis d'une même compagnie
j'ai jamais vu la réaction des clients
recevoir leurs commandes m
et quand faut vraiment que tu t'arranges
pour le confirmer sur pie gens fous
petit dessin agréable bunia comptes note
faire confiance il doute pourquoi qui la
cosmétique en minute des mannequins mais
en vue d'amener ma poche me suis dit
elle je passe des filles vont aimer ceux
ci je le fais comme moi j'ai envie que
je l'aïe si je trouvais que dans le
cosmétique
c'est vraiment pas méchant mais je
trouvais que depuis maintenant une fille
comme 10 watts east cette grande dame le
jeu trois quarts un groupe gap dans le
cosmétique québécois canadiens qui
s'offre un défi nam en danger même toute
l'année autour d'un mois qu'ils se
trompent tu spurs est trop complexe et
satie vont c'est pareil devant lyon
qu'un sentiment d'appartenance à une
marque canadienne y en avait eu aucun
aucun aucun aucun
jfr on leur en donne pas une centrale à
partager
et puis en fait c'est à genk c'est dans
le monde c'est la once le tissu d'un nom
de ses cheveux ce que je souhaitais pas
le moment
vantis montlouis dérivés c'est ma
meilleure forme et si ça mérite le
règlement négocié son début
moi je travaille avec eux c'est tout et
quatrièmement je marque la campagne
cosmétiques aussi ses délicieuses légaux
qui font des trucs de fille puis vous
avez vous vu de santé dans un chalet à
stoneham play sont comme on est donc on
brise thermique sont plaints de mon plus
ces gens savent à qui s'appelait
d'acquérir données indiquent qu'avant
des viols des gueux la grèce où il ya
des gars arrivent comme anti sida
brauman la boue la budweiser et qu'on
faisait danser juste pour ce match
airship temps avant de trouver un nom au
sein de la compagnie klaus mystique les
boissons comme en rien tout les noms
qu'on ne trouverait alors qu'on arrive
et empêcher son avocat puis revenez puis
c'était tout posséder ma musique par
l'oréal et libon non mais ce que les
millions peuvent se trouver dans la
métropole n'en reste un peu chic ce sera
juste dessiné aux femmes parce que je
trouve que les vrais b vraiment moins en
maintenant cela pour les deux mois c'est
gentil mot mettons il ya souvent du
linge comme douce blais blindée db
tichenor affaires en main ces gens-là
fois j'achèterai mais c'est sûr mais en
fait on me demande souvent ce soir
keromen du monde laisse non mais si je
pourrais pas marquer ces 100 % mais mais
on me demande souvent qui je pense est
rendu une question de oui c'est une
question avance de tabakh de modeuse
sans même une forme de vie des vrais un
beau mais là ce sera une question de aux
six mètres et ont les nerfs
tous les yeux le comité qui a un autre
compagne 120 qui j'en ai une scène mais
tu peux pas me parler non plus non mais
vous même et si ça mais c'est plus une
question de tout ce que tu mets ton
énergie parce qu'après ce canton
tribunes on m'a trompé moi je me dis le
chevauchement son espace et miquelon le
font confiance donc je pense que si je
vendrai des laveuses sécheuses pas tant
qu'elle ferait c'est une incroyable
quand est-ce que j'ai l'impression
d'avoir joué toute la deuxième partie de
nuit puis moi je pense dans la nuit
plaisir est toujours j'ai partagé cette
nuit gens préfèrent visiter ou des
crèmes pour l'éléphant l'évènement
femmes enceintes ce type sont très bien
dans le cosmétique je trouve ça après
une belle ligne et et pourquoi pas ta
casquette cosmétiques ont fait quelqu'un
comme pilote comme à ce qu'elle fait
tout sans conséquence d'un jour je veux
avoir des enfants a dit sarah angoisse
parce que je me dis que ce qui est soit
avancée dans ta vie plus que tu veux
vouloir totaux fournit tout ce que tu as
dit faire une gamme ligne de linge de
maternité hinault et ça c'était les
filtres de volontat mettait vraiment ses
pentes et le thé comme c'est vraiment
des cannes de tous comme point de départ
et je pense qu'après tout une question
c'était de choisir ton énergie jamais
parce que lui ce pauvre elle ok tu prend
quelque chose piller team est en faute
au petit le mans non c'est sûr que non
est ce que si l'on tape halifax l'usp
une option mais est ce qui est béton de
vendre son lait où je mets ton ventre
des cosmétiques dans des boutiques ça
vous tue la peine face aux avocats des
parties moi je crois vraiment
aman vraiment vraiment vraiment beaucoup
au centre d'achats danville je pense que
c'est primordial
je pense que le client a besoin de ce
besoin de vivre un conte hacker besoin
si je veux tu achètes une bande à part
boulangerie du coin comme squattons dont
le boulanger paul effectifs ça à ma faim
dans le vêtement les cheveux de nous en
faire un service à la clientèle qui in 5
passes la fille a juste besoin de faire
de la chemise est belle est vraiment
belle et bien fait s'il ya des clients
qui n'hésite pas à citer de noms mais je
suis prêt à mettre un pantalon noir
parce que vous la mjcs moi je file à cet
égard le sol en face à la mairie ce que
tu veux t'en distinctes et ben en voilà
une mauvaise et on a besoin d'être
j'avais besoin de ce contact là encore
la pandémie mais cette énigme avant
l'est encore p tit moche
moi ça me crève le coeur devant toutes
ces entreprises là en forme d'achat qui
sont obligés de fermer parce qu'elles
sont c'est horrible c'est horrible mais
il ya quelque chose qui vous qui tourne
au tvt les centres d'achats se comprend
des fonds d'investissement immobilier
vous que ça génère de l'argent matinée
et vouloir mettre juste leur mettre des
idées tout à tout le monde et loyal
pourcentage je prends 10 % des ventes à
titre je vais en fait sa thèse en
journée ça va pour qu'ils trouvent aux
mille défaut faut qu'on ait le monde
l'aimait les gens ont besoin
moi je moi si j'avais la structure
financière pour la faire moi je voulais
le faire je l'ouvrirai une petite gare
de la capitale ont soufflé non moi je
réagirais en sandales expérience il est
vraiment l'ouvrir mythique l'hôpital on
ne peut plus parce qu'on attend on perd
de l'argent et je m'étais et on le
prophète mais c'est pas quelque chose
que j'enlèverai être ici page allait
proposer jarlier crasnault symons pige
la horde histoire histoire de l'art
oratoire holmes dans leurs grosses aïn
madhi gifu gros pour rentrer dans tes
dents se montrent plus je me dis
maintenant tout rôle dans le film
plus tu vois jean régis pas tu mets en
allant vers les sacs matane naples et
toute ta mythique la clients c'est ça
qu'ils achètent aussi on va te rendre
dans boutique on veut tout vitré dedans
dans se tient un restaurant proche m'a
dit il faut dire en votre la catch qui
m'ont pour offrir aux gens un crew good
un godillot
bonjour monsieur s'agit des questions je
me verrais dans un coin à gauche en
rentrant galerie le gars m'a dit bon on
fait passer une bonne journée
fin mai mais juste de retourner je le
sens en irak à côté d'autres affaires
big ben en fait pas du tout ce qui me
dérangerait c'est quelque chose que
j'aimerais face jusqu'ici surtout qui
est vraiment différente si nous ça
impliquerait qu'il faudrait faire pour
l'amender vêtements spécifiquement pour
eux parce que souvent mais ils veulent
pas que tu vente sur le web est vraiment
fort à ce que tu y mets we thank you so
m'intéressait mais ça part tout est bon
partout dit mais j'avais mon ip j'avais
rencontré les gens dynamite aussi pour
leur proposer c'est parce que personne
ne voulait la faire je me suis fait
racheter par tout le monde c'est une 1,4
et pas pour l'instant parce que dans le
fond c'est une question de gestion c'est
une gestion d'inventaire d'employés
weinstock ses murs ses rangs pas moins
le web ça me passionne la beauté même le
cosmétique
alors qu'on nous le propos est ici pas
d'un plan
c'est sûr que nous on est plus cher qu'à
la pharmacie mon nez - chaque os effort
effectué va rentrer à pharmacie doit
avoir de mascara maintenant j'ai pas
d'user des charges existe une question
de vue sinon voudrais commencer web avec
le cosmétique justement pour peuvent
vivre ce genre arc ses chances qu'a fait
maintenant vont faire presque développer
ici c'est viguen ces genres et un gros
travail qui fait que ça vous ce métier
je l'enlèverai pas sauf que j'ai pas la
connaissance pour le faire de dire on va
ouvrir des magasins mais je moi je pense
c'est l'axé la cli tout dont
l'expérience client et est essentielle
même si le sait ce qu on a empanné me
met vraiment une question de gestion
technique
je passerai la meilleure pour gérer ça
c'est un autre affaire compliquée pis
pour ceux qui manquent
le cndp resto in store ou encore la
dynamique pour me permettre mis des
collections d or aux mondiaux mais cela
c'était pour paul jerry choisi en tout
les freins structurels ce joli moment je
vais envoyer chez vous mais je t'ai pas
c'est important
tu parlais de travailler pour les les
bedaines de femmes enceintes et dessus
dans les plans rapprochés pour toi
d'être une femme trans et ben en fait on
en parle c'est justement mon tome on est
prêt c'est un format clé il y avait six
a fait un match d'enfer sont avec moi
qui était quatrième année de résidence
apprécié fête sa cinquième année de
résidence principale et par son
fellowship à toronto pendant un an
ça fait six mois qu'ils pratiquent dans
sa pratique à lui fait non c'était
vraiment dit qu'ils allaient rentrer en
italie on va voyager on va profiter de
la vie les deux parce qu'on ne touche
pas été très bon capitaine a en fait
l'eau j'en ai profité pour mettre à gaz
au fond que l'on se trouve un peu a
comme on peut en profiter tant qui sauf
que l'on cible qui pèsera la page des
trucs mais je pense peut-être commencer
peut-être a failli me ton après l'été ou
un peu plus tard mais si on y paie ton
n'est pas full l'appel c'est plus le
fait de dire si ça me tenterait cet ado
marronne famille et moi j'ai 30 ans le
jeu peu vieilli les mêlées ont pu
motiver entre 35 et ses mots s'y fait
mais si peu on n'a pas le genre de
l'appel sauf que je pense que j'espère
ça serait pas mal mais votre question le
mais peu dans notre horaire ça se peut
compter on est vraiment des gens qui
écoutent nous le soir l'on arrive à
maison pillon sucre qui après 16 comme
tout est ce que tu vas pas au moins
j'aurai une coupe de courriel ou un mot
si pire on estime à tort dit on
travaille on mange tous notre job c'est
notre passe-temps moi c'est comme mot
quand je vois pas travailler tu
travailles quand j'aime vraiment ce que
je fais gendre m a vraiment vraiment
vraiment fait que ça se peut que si je
pense c'est qu'on veut poste tombe est
juste là dedans mais j'avais une
conversation qui n'a mis autrefois qui
disait que l avec son chat me pensais
avoir des enfants c'est à vendre
confinement commencé à en parler avant
la pandémie tout
le partant des métiers envoyer à
d'autres amis qui avaient des enfants et
des jeunes enfants parents amis puis la
réception chaume sont d ailleurs quand
ça va finir le on va les clubs et à
berlin
puis j'en rêvais d'un bond de zinc or
avant de passer à table tandis que nous
c'est eux qu'on se rend compte qu'on a
comme peu foule vie qu on this qu'orange
a vécu ensemble climatique n'est
vraiment beaucoup manger était de dire
comprendre moi j'ai jamais dit je vais
prendre deux semaines de vacances les
chemins et deux semaines dans un autre
pays j'aime ce tunnel affectés mais
encore le on a des amis qui ont des
enfants et à seraing a couvert qui sont
partis avec marc gaubert avait six mois
ayant fait trois morts dans les landes
et du tout 1 126 fiscal qu'il a reviré
24 enfin talent l'angleterre était clair
que je pense sont allés deux sets
partout et les 4 4 cela en fait un
voyage sac à dos en angleterre ou de pas
mal comme troyes se regardent ces gens
réputés comme tu es des gens qui ont des
enfers moi je trouve qu'ils ont l'air
d'être une meilleure version de main en
se démenant fait j'ai envie existent
mais ils ont déménagé bourdeau 28 qu'on
soit en gros plus gros peut regarder les
autres
on va faire une gare d'arrivée sera
compliqué vous déménagez dans quel coin
et on entre et on est là dans du gros ce
que je vois les photos avec qu'un
tellement de monde qui gère l'étape sont
comme vous êtes comme trois mêmes
bureaux puis un laptop au bout de la
table quand même y'a des plex classe
partout le 15 mai t on était en train et
en bus les antennes entrepôts peuvent
pas se croiser pour cette famille qui
tient la qualité du son est sûr que mes
ouailles tpiy le 6 juin à nantes
quand on engage monde dont il aime icône
habité par le ce temps on attend si
c'est pour rester en chine 80 et la
personne peut flamber sur facebook et
fouet mais faudrait ferme et on a des
défis de santé mais ils savent on
engagement qui trouvent ça drôle mais je
le lance et poli par les gens mais ce
serait un bon pas vraiment non
merci inflame merci les gars vraiment
l'fun
merci vraiment cause de boston pour nom
finalement t'es pas ce type était
tellement autrèche pastore pourrait
s'attendre à la fois tradition romaine
je pense que c'est vraiment le fun et
nicole d'être heureux toi toi ici
absolument
thq demain ben oui mais oui moi en fait
souvent fait casser c'est une classe à
deux premiers employés l'on vient mais
en fait moi ce que j'ai l'impression t
on vous en avait parlé un peu temps toul
mais c'est j'ai vraiment l'impression en
fait d'être travaillé sur 20 sur un
projet commun pour un projet commun sait
plus qui est travaillé pour quelqu'un en
fit la fin qui fait quoi ça c'est
vraiment cool j'ai l'impression qu'on a
toutes un peu chacun noter cette
expertise l'invité pileux catherine
quéré qui arrive qui est qui va
embarquer dans cette dynamique là aussi
enfin que fait quoi c'est vraiment plus
cool de l'europe et des grands prix mais
ils comprennent pas le même quand
j'étais jeune je servais la messe les
pressions de paris pour jésus non mais
baisse des jeux c'est parce que c'est
des fois
reste qu'on engage plus de monde m'est
témoin je suis temps mais non plus fait
tellement faire des baisants victime ne
puisse comme même jésus pis sa gang
mitterrand 11 12 10 pendant pendant que
benoît rey
en 2007 roszak partenaires vars et
insiste comprennent tous une photo d'un
sur une longue table mais c'était comme
si on parle encore aujourd'hui debout
s'est passé qui jésus parce que vous
n'êtes pas la musique mais non mais
féclaz puis je passe est important d
autre que nous en effet y tint projet
ouais mais ça c'est le point je pense il
présentait dans un projet commun qui que
ce soit pour mettons travailler sous
toile
non si c'est avec toi vent c'est ce
qu'elle fait depuis longtemps j'ai
demandé à mon tatouine camille non pas
un cahier des employés parce que jacques
à chaque jour cela c'est qu'il estime je
passe plus des entrevues titre à moins
que c'est un poste que tout comme la
chose est sûre les entreposer figaro
pierre car mixte qui boitillait comme
simone apparaît dans des cahiers d'école
adamczak boucle le nom de ses cheveux ça
que j'ai demandé lundi la large des
tracts raïssi piqué ce qu'ils ont envie
si son pays à temps plein puis camille a
rappelé qu'il anime arrive que je parle
c'est parce qu'il manque peu mais
maintenant je veux pas mais camille a
regretté qu'un cheveu crois que je suis
gentil comme ça en tout cas sachez que
maintenant mais camille je le fais parce
que georges me soucie d'eux j'aurais
notre seul go bureau il rentre au bureau
comme agent s'était mis le matin puis
jetée dans mon bureau et il me comme
aujourd'hui encore des pauvres a dit il
comme partiront une excuse moi je suis
dit il au rendez vous en dise quoi ton
nom tu vas me cendrillon ici attendent
rien tu vraiment des ailes
ok t'es beau un dieu mais ça m'est égal
je dirais jamais mon livre les jei
personnes falloir un livre à chacun avec
ma photo met ça face à vallet de
l'enquêté jusqu'à généralement de faire
se lever quitter l'école mais dix
matches à risques comme mondou semaine
les moyens d'arrêter foule au terme d'un
film au pardon cette année donc je suis
content c'était très important de
prendre soin des gens qui sont autour de
nous qui nous si on avait nos employés
dont la plus nicole donc ça me désole
c'est que lorsqu'on plus fort pour qu'il
soit heureux devrait avoir une tête
façon mais réattu qu'on paye t tampon
australie fait des services en temps
c'est quelque chose me dit que je pense
de plus en plus non mais c'est drôle
mais les acquis coupe c'est l'ego le
juste pouvait ça coûte à rien non mais
là la pression mentale que nous les
femmes on ne met ça nous enlève un poids
sur les épaules de comme parfait dans
une nouvelle double puis j'étais petite
usine comment ces deux monstres il faut
comme souvent dans une inconnue
je m'adresse un tampon tu es jeune a eu
l'oeil en on en met partout le chile
pharmacie et salles de bains sont
pleines on leur demande au fait
qu'est-ce qui voulait en acheter marque
qui voulaient faire des blagues mais ce
extraordinaire mais toutes sortes cilaos
tcc comme tpiy
ce poster ça ça on aimerait une traite
les attentions de ce soir que ça compte
ça contribue grandement à comme ton
appartenance attend mieux de travail
puis comme commenté confortant notre
travail c'est qu'il sait s'il ya des
entrepreneurs qui nous écoutent pas en
fait si les autoroutes vont écouter mon
trip est ce qu'on va bien si on
répondrait parce que tu drop du golfe
merci faut que notre fils tu tomberas
n'ai rien aux chiffres au départ je
trouve que le tysabri peut plus pauvres
ont à chaque mot l'âge éventuel tout
puis comme ça c'est quoi ça c'est quoi
je vais de temps mais on était six amis
j'aime épaules et le côté école là tu te
dis que j'aurais mis alors l'école plus
longtemps parce que j'étais je trouve
qu'ils me manquent peut-être des notions
sont des enfants mais changement taux
vraiment vraiment bien vite et si ça
faisait si chaud un conseil à donner
c'est comme ces moments naïveté sa plus
belle chose que j'ai pu je répète à
faire que les autres prophètes parce
qu'ils savaient ce qu'ils lisent et même
en chine dément pas ce que je fais que
je le fais pas ça l'enjeu maintenant
c'est l'intérêt ne pas avoir peur de
poser des questions toutes ses formes
est gentiment juge quand je comprends
pas je le dis le puits il n'a pas
d'avoir l'air comme précis bon mais
finalement ce qui pose jamais question
ouais tu veux potes non la fois ça m'est
arrivé puis j'aurais pas dû faire ça
mais je sois capitaine parle qui me dit
des mots que je comprends pas huawei
nokia ont installé le système de paie
ici deux autres idiots puis c'est comme
l'a fait me paraît père me dit tout ce
que j'avais besoin pour instaurer le
système de paye le plus à me parler
comme si je commençais seul comme si
j'avais de quoi me parlait plus j'étais
comme j'avais mort d'homme dans le
saloum and company je comprends pas de
ce qui se passe là bas j'avais panne il
a un amant qui revenu québec quand j'ai
commencé dès 2 3 ans promène pas de quoi
faire avant des employés qu'il faut que
tu ans voire avant le 28 février de
chaque année et on colle bien au
sommaire un dieu tout le monde par son
amante agit pas vraiment à ouais ça ne
manque qu'un avertissement ça marrant
moi j'appelle draine québec au colisée
j'ai une amende mais je sais même pas
celle de comprendre pourquoi si staff
exide afité surgir [ __ ] comprends pas
trop là un an que la fille j panier
graphique jeunes québec a plus qu'on
définit comme ça fait trois ans que tu
en as fap sais pas c'est quoi ben non je
posais quoi bein c'est génial j'embarque
m'a dit tu peux pas savoir c'est quoi tu
peux pas savoir
je suis mise à nu les cheminées
imprimons 4 comme jean le cam à des
cotisations d'intesa c'est pourquoi j'ai
acquis parfait puis je prends soin ou à
dubai mall franck est un faux nom près
de tabac car accroché j'ai dit oh mon
dieu
vainqueur à chaque année à cet engin
alan anderson
car mr on a très bien mais qui est juste
et droit jérémy le relever une somme
heureux merci chercher car running gag
décor table en table se poseraient des
comptes a mis cette époque qui peut être
dit c'est drôle parce qu'évidemment on a
chanté encore appliquons à damas et on
est encore pas qui pouvait jeter comme
si vous êtes des petits mais ses rues le
champ de ces camps m libre quant à mais
on prend pour acquis que le monde font
leur job parfaitement car c'est vraiment
un pot de 56 pays hors professionnel tu
penses que mais finalement non non et
nous le jetons on est on est on est chez
white depuis cinq mois les environs
c'est la plus belle chose que ces puits
en nationwide parce qu'on a un certain
chiffre d'affaires à ses hôtes ils
prennent en compte tenu de lille
mais là je veux dire c'est la plus belle
chose qui nous est paru si sûr que c'est
plus dispendieux mais on sent si c'est
eux qui ont travaillé pour me trouver
mon institution financière ils y ont
négocié avec l autriche quand je masse
agents comme si j allais dans mon brevet
on voit ces ensembles distincts autre
façon de faire qui sont ici si c'est
vraiment important
tu es dessus avait d'autres engagements
comptable mais si ce que je me demandais
jeux mobiles en question ce matin
justement
mais en fait ça dépasse juste que nous
leur comptabilité vraiment simple parce
que on est comme pote contient doigts de
large en personne et on a dit contre ça
va monter en hyper direct par chiffrait
à 1 vente s'était pas tenue de livres il
pose conçu contre x
des cas présent un coup coeur nous y
voyons trois mois fin aux rapports de
taxes pire parce qu'ils y retravaille
plus assure que mes saisons ils ont dit
5e qui oppose
des taxis tendance tout comme tant que
quiconque ce qui peut qui m'ont agences
existent la tenue de livres soutenant
qu'elle a comprend toute cette chaîne
mais ça on n'est pas des gros 120 juste
au canada comme aux états unis on n'a
pas les grosses réclamations de taxes à
part la beauté si peu t les seuls gens
qu'on paye sens à ces gens fed expire au
post canada note lynch équipe aux
espaces compris
non si ce n'est en tout cas le comptable
il ya fait un bureau dans leurs bureaux
en open trot bureau guen place pour six
jours de gand - c'est ça si jamais à
quelqu'un d'important qui est vraiment
une porte et comme les bureaux faire si
on engage et jacques le guen porte kate
moss l'impasse dans la couverture
choisie quand on quand arrive plus
dénoncé t on n'a pas encore mais je sais
pas quand parce que je pense qu'avant et
ça va venir aux mains
tu peux je peu près 6 degrés merci